आई थिंक आई एम लाइव राइट
आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
यस
हेलो हेलो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव गाइस नाउ एक
बार मुझे कंफर्म कर दीजिए ऑडियो वीडियो सब
कुछ सही है एक बार मुझे सभी कंफर्म कर
दीजिए गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबॉडी नमस्ते सभी
को प्लीज एवरीबडी कंफर्म इफ आई एम लाइव
एंड ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ सही है। एक बार
सभी लोग फटाफट कंफर्म कीजिए। मैं एक बार
चेक कर लेता हूं क्योंकि काफी ज्यादा
नेटवर्क प्रॉब्लम हुआ है आज एंड काफी
ज्यादा
ट्रबल शूटिंग के बाद क्लास जो है वो
फाइनली स्टार्ट हो रही है। इसके लिए
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी। काफी डिले हुआ है।
क्लास 7:00 pm से 8 ऑलमोस्ट 8:20 हो चुके
हैं। एंड कुछ नेटवर्क इशू आ गया था। कुछ
इशूज़ सिस्टम में भी आ गए थे। जिस वजह से
यह डिले हुआ है। एंड आई होप कि आप सब काफी
वेट कर रहे थे [हंसी]
सेशन का। ठीक है। चलिए कोई बात नहीं देर
आए, दुरुस्त आए। चलते हैं। स्टार्ट
करेंगे। आज की क्लास काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
होने वाली है। आज का बहुत ही एक
इंपॉर्टेंट क्लास है ये क्योंकि इस क्लास
का वेट आप सब में से सभी लोग कर रहे थे
एंड काफी लोग डिमांड भी कर रहे थे कि सर
ऐसी क्लास लाओ। राइट? तो आपको टाइटल से तो
पता चल गया होगा। आपने देख ही लिया होगा।
पहले भी मैंने बता दिया था कि आज हम एसओसी
की लैब सेटअप करेंगे। एक शानदार
इंटरेस्टिंग सा लैब होम लैब लोकल लैब जहां
पे आप एसओसी की एक लैब सेटअप करके एंड आप
जो है एसओसी के एनवायरमेंट का मजा ले सकते
हैं। एंड एसओसी वाली जैसे एनवायरमेंट में
आप एसओसी का जो भी प्रैक्टिस है वो कर
सकते हैं घर पे बैठे-बैठे। ठीक है? कुछ
इसी तरीके का एनवायरमेंट इसी तरीके का
सेटअप आपको कंपनी के अंदर भी मिल जाता है।
वह एक ब्रॉड लेवल पर होता है। बड़े स्केल
पर होता है। बड़े लेवल पर होता है। एंड
यहां पे हम छोटे लेवल पे कर रहे हैं। और
चीजों को बस जानना है, सीखना है। मेन
मोटिव हमारा ये होना चाहिए कि हमें चीज़ ही
जो चीजें हैं वो आनी चाहिए। एग्जैक्टली कि
एग्जैक्टली क्या हो रहा है, कैसे हम कर पा
रहे हैं? ये सारी चीजें आपको पता पता होनी
चाहिए। ठीक है? चलिए बिफोर वी स्टार्ट
जस्ट वेटिंग फॉर एवरीबडी टू जॉइ
सभी को आ जाने देते हैं। सभी लोगों को
जुड़ जाने देते हैं। काफी लोग 40 प्लस लोग
आ चुके हैं ऑलरेडी। 40 प्लस पीपल आर हियर
एंड दैट्स ग्रेट कि अभी तक इस सीरीज में
लोग अभी तक बने हुए हैं आप लोग। एंड दैट्स
ग्रेट। रियली ग्रेट। चलिए मैं यहां पे एक
बार
ओके।
आप में से कई लोगों का यह सवाल था। वैसे
इस सेशन के लिए इस सेशन की डिमांड थी कई
लोगों की।
तो मैं ये तो मैं ये सेशन फाइनली लेकर आ
चुका हूं। मैं यहां पे एक साइड में फोन भी
रखता हूं आपकी चैट्स को थोड़ा देखता रहता
हूं फोन के अंदर में। ठीक है? ओके।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] चलिए। सो आज जो
है सेशन जो है वो अ एसओसी का लैब सेटअप
करेंगे। कोई थ्यरी क्लास आज की बिल्कुल भी
नहीं है। आज की पूरी प्रैक्टिकल क्लास
होने वाली है। फुल ऑन प्रैक्टिकल होने
वाला है। कोई थ्यरी नहीं है। कुछ भी नहीं
है। जो भी कांसेप्ट जो भी चीजें मैं
बताऊंगा वो ड्यूरिंग द प्रैक्टिकल सेशन
ड्यूरिंग जो हम करेंगे उसी के अंदर में
मैं आपको बताने वाला हूं। ठीक है? तो आपको
हर एक चीज जो है वो थोड़ा ध्यान से देखना
है। क्योंकि आज जो हम प्रैक्टिकल करने
वाले हैं, जो हम चीजें जानने वाले हैं, वो
वो बहुत ही बहुत ही इंटरेस्टिंग होगा।
आपको बड़ा मजा आएगा आज की क्लास में। मैं
आपको इस बात की गारंटी देता हूं। आप हर एक
पॉइंट पर कुछ नया सीखेंगे, कुछ नया
समझेंगे। कुछ नई चीजें आपको पता चलेंगी आज
के क्लास के अंदर में। देखो अभी तक हमने
एसओसी की क्लासेस करी है। अब होता क्या है
जब आप जनरली एसओसी की कोर्सेज वगैरह ये सब
चीजें करते हो। बहुत सारी जगह पर आपको
एसओसी के लैब सेटअप सबसे पहले करा दिए
जाते हैं। सबसे स्टार्टिंग में ही लैब
सेटअप करा दिया जाता है। बट वह लैब सेटअप
सबसे स्टार्टिंग में या पहले करना किसी भी
तरीके से वैलिड नहीं होता है। किसी भी
तरीके से सही नहीं है। क्योंकि लैब सेटअप
करने के टाइम आपको बहुत सारी चीजों की
जानकारी होनी चाहिए। स्प्लंक का आईडिया
होना चाहिए। राइट? बहुत सारी चीजों के
बारे में आपको आईडिया होना चाहिए। तब जाके
आप स्प्लक डैशबोर्ड क्या होता है? कैसे
स्प्लंक सेटअप करते हैं? इंस्टॉलेशन करते
हैं? ये सब पता होना चाहिए। तभी आप कर
सकते हो। नहीं तो नहीं कर पाओगे। सिंपल।
तो इसलिए मैंने यह जो वीडियो है यह सबसे
एंड में रखा था आपके लिए एंड सबसे एंड में
आपके लिए मैं यह क्लास लेकर आया हूं। आज
बहुत लोग पूछ रहे हैं सर आज लास्ट को
क्लास है क्या? डीसीजीएसपी कोर्स इज वेरी
गुड। थैंक यू वेरी मच टीवी सिक्स
डीसीजीएसपी कोर्स इज़ बेस्ट। थैंक यू वेरी
मच मिस्टर भुजेल। थैंक यू वेरी मच। ओके।
तो आज आज लास्ट क्लास आज नहीं है बट इसके
बाद अब बहुत कम क्लासेस बची हैं इस सीरीज
एंड होने से पहले। उसके बाद इंटरव्यू
प्रिपरेशन, जॉब हंटिंग और ये सब चीजें
चालू होंगी। साथ में सर्टिफिकेशन वाला चीज
मैं प्रोसेस स्टेप आपको बताऊंगा कि क्या
स्टेप से आपको सर्टिफिकेशन जो है इसकी
एसओसीएल वन की सर्टिफिकेट हम आपको
प्रोवाइड करेंगे। पहले जैसे मैंने बोला था
सारे लोगों को सर्टिफिकेट सर्टिफिकेट नहीं
मिलने वाली है। एक
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
छोटा सा प्यारा सा एक एग्जाम होगा आपका जो
एग्जाम क्लियर करेंगे उनको सर्टिफिकेशन
मिलेगी डेफ्रोनिक्स के साइट से एंड वो एक
वैलिड और बहुत ही ऑथेंटिक सर्टिफिकेशन
होगी जिसको आप जॉब के टाइम में डेफिनेटली
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। ठीक है?
ओके। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
नहीं सिक्स सेवन क्लासेस नहीं है। देयर इज
नो सिक्स सेवन क्लासेस। इस क्लास के बाद
टू और थ्री क्लासेस मैक्सिमम दो क्लासेस
और होंगी शायद या दो ही होंगी शायद एक या
दो क्लासेस ऐसे होंगी जो आपकी बची है वो
होंगी। उसके बाद सीरीज आपकी एंड हो जाएगी।
कई सालों की आपकी कई टाइम महीनों की आपकी
जो है वो मेहनतें पूरी हो गई। इस सीरीज के
एंड होने के साथ ही हो जाएंगी कि चलो भाई
ये कंप्लीट हुआ। चलिए हम स्टार्ट करते
हैं। उसके पहले मैं आपको कुछ चीजें बहुत
क्लियर कट आज के क्लास के पहले बताना
चाहता हूं। सबसे पहले अह ऐज़ यूज़ुअल
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च कर लीजिएगा।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च करेंगे हमारा चैनल
मिलेगा YouTube का। आप इस पे लाइव सेक्शन
में आइएगा। यहां लाइव सेक्शन में आके किसी
भी एसओसी क्लास जो लास्ट एसओसी क्लास है
इसकी वीडियो को ओपन कर लीजिएगा। यहां
डिस्क्रिप्शन [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
में जाइएगा। यहां आपको दो लिंक मिलेंगे।
एक WhatsApp चैनल का, एक WhatsApp ग्रुप
का। WhatsApp चैनल को जाकर फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। 13,000 से ज्यादा लोग हमसे जुड़े
हैं। किसी भी तरह की अपडेट सबसे पहले आपको
चैनल पे ही मिलती है। और ओवरऑल टोटल हर एक
तरह की अपडेट आपको चैनल पे सबसे पहले
मिलेगी। एक WhatsApp ग्रुप है जो एस एसओसी
से स्पेसिफिक ग्रुप है। सोचो इस ग्रुप में
कितने लोग हैं कि ये सेवंथ ग्रुप बनी है।
छह ग्रुप फुल हो चुके हैं। यानी कि 6000
लोग तो ऑलरेडी ग्रुप में हैं। ये सेवंथ
ग्रुप है। यहां इस सीरीज के रिगार्डिंग जो
भी अपडेट्स आती हैं जो रिसोर्सेज हैं वो
सबसे पहले आपको यहां पे मिलने वाली है। ये
दोनों ज्वाइन जरूर कर लीजिएगा। ये Lindin
पे ये मेरी Lindin प्रोफाइल है। आप चाह तो
मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। यहां पे Lindin
पे ही आप डिफ़्रॉनिक्स जब सर्च कर लेंगे तो
यू विल गेट द डिफ़्रॉनिक्स साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। हमारी कंपनी का जो Lindin पेज
है वो आपको मिल जाएगा। आप इसे भी जरूर से
जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यहां कंपनी से
रिगार्डिंग कंपनी के तरफ से जो भी अपडेट्स
जो भी चीजें हैं वो आपको मिलेंगी। जैसे
अभी हमारा करंट हमारा जो oसin प्लेट
प्लेटफार्म है साइबर Intel जो कि एक ओसन
प्लेटफार्म एडवांस ओसन प्लेटफार्म है
ओसिंट इंटेलिजेंस प्लेटफार्म है वो जो है
कंप्लीट अपग्रेड में आने वाला है न्यू ल्च
होने वाला है ये सब कुछ यूआई वगैरह चेंज
हो जाएगा यहां इस प्लेटफार्म को यूजर्स और
एलए लॉ इनफोर्समेंट एजेंसीज जैसे कि साइबर
सेल वाले सीबीआई वाले इंडियन नेवी
इंटेलिजेंस ये सब लोग इस प्लेटफार्म को
यूज करते हैं। एंड यहां पे वो ओसेंट के
एडवांस इंटेलिजेंस अ उस के पावर को एडवांस
इंटेलिजेंस का यूज करते हुए कई सारे
इंटेलिजेंस रिसोर्सेज को क्यूरेट करके
हमने वहां पे यहां पे चीजें सर्विज दी
हैं। आप इसको यूज़ कर सकते हैं। डेफिनेटली
यूजर पोर्टल पे साइन अप करके। एलए सिर्फ
एलए वालों के लिए है। यह पूरा रिवैंप होने
वाला है। पूरा नई बहुत सारी अपडेट्स आने
वाली है। इसको जरूर ट्राई एक बार कीजिएगा।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
तो बहुत सारी अपडेट्स आपको इस Lindin पेज
पे मिलेगी। यह डिफ्रॉनिक्स डिफ्रॉनिक्स का
lindin Instagram पेज है डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी हैंडल से प्लीज डू फॉलो इट फॉर
इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल पोस्ट्स रील्स कंटेंट्स
यहां पे जैसे एक एआई हैंड रिटन हैंड रिटेन
नोट्स है एआई की यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
रील्स आपको मिलते हैं अलग-अलग 30 पैराटर्स
फॉर पेंटेस्टर्स दे डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट
कंटेंट्स ये हमारी वेबसाइट है। आप इस पे
आके इस नंबर पे हमसे कांटेक्ट कर सकते
हैं। किसी भी तरह की क्वेरी क्वेश्चन हो
कांटेक्ट कीजिए। वेबसाइट को एक्सप्लोर कर
लीजिए। हालांकि ये चेंज होने वाला है बहुत
ही लुक एंड फील में बहुत जल्द आपको मिलेगा
न्यू वेबसाइट लुक और ये एकडमी पे जाके
हमारे कोर्सर्सेस को आप एक्सप्लोर कर सकते
हैं। ऑफर्ड बाय अस जो कि पेड कोर्सर्सेस
होते हैं। ठीक है? चलिए ये सारी चीजें
कहानी हो गई। अब आज की जो क्लास है उसमें
हमें थोड़ा टाइम चाहिए। आज मैं क्लास जो
कराऊंगा आपको ये क्लास
पूरी प्रैक्टिकल है। तो सबसे पहले एसओसी
का लैब जो सेटअप करेंगे तो मैं एक बार
पहले
यहां पर इसको क्लोज करते हैं।
नोटपड ओपन कर लेते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? मैं यहां पे
इसको भी क्लोज करते हैं।
हां। मैं यहां पर पहले आपको कुछ चीजें
आज की क्लास के बारे में बता रहे हैं।
एसओसी [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
लैब सेटअप। अब ये जो लैब सेटअप करेंगे
इसमें हम किस तरह का आर्किटेक्चर रखने
वाले हैं, मैं आपको बता देता हूं। ठीक है?
इसमें हम ऑनलाइन
वाइट बोर्ड का ओपन कर लिया। वाइट बोर्ड
ओपन करते हैं आपको ताकि मैं थोड़ा
क्लियरली बता सकूं। यहां पे किस तरह का
पूरा आज का सेटअप होने वाला है वो मैं
बताऊंगा। मैं आपको बिल्कुल बेसिक से
बिल्कुल स्टार्ट से ये लैब सेटअप करना
बताऊंगा। हर एक चीज बताऊंगा। तो आपको
ज्यादा टेंशन लेने की जरूरत नहीं है। ठीक
है? चलिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ये लैब सेटअप जो होगा कुछ इस तरीके का
होगा कि ये आपका है Windows लैपटॉप। जो
आपका जो आपका होस्ट लैपटॉप है। ये आपका
क्या है?
होस्ट लैपटॉप है। Windows लैपटॉप। ठीक है?
इस पर आपने सेटअप किया है वीएमवेयर। यह
आपने वीएमवेयर इस पर इंस्टॉल किया है। मान
लो यह इंस्टॉल करना पड़ेगा आपको। अगर करा
है ऑलरेडी तो अच्छी बात है। वीएमवेयर की
जगह पे आप वर्चुअल बॉक्स भी यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। आपकी चॉइस है। कोई दिक्कत। उसके बाद
यह सेटअप कुछ ऐसे काम करेगा कि यहां पे
आपकी होगी काली मशीन।
सॉरी यह थोड़ा सा इसको ना मैं वैसे कर
देता हूं। इसको मैं ऐसे लिख देता हूं।
टेक्स्ट में लिख देता हूं ताकि आपको
ज्यादा थोड़ी क्लेरिटी मिलेगी। यहां पर
होगी आपकी
काली लinक्स जो मशीन है वह
बोल्ड कर देते हैं।
थोड़ा सा इसको बड़ा कर देते हैं। हां जी।
यहां पे आपकी काली लinक्स होगी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सॉरी। उसके बाद यहां पे आपका
Windows
10 या 11 होगा जो कि यहां पर आपका स्ट
होगा। ये होगा और देन यहां पे जो है आपकी
U12 होगी और U12 के अंदर स्प्लक आपका चल
रहा होगा। U12 सर्वर यहां होगा। U12 का
सर्वर इंस्टॉल करेंगे हम। सर्वर वर्जन एंड
उसके ऊपर हम स्प्लक को चलाएंगे। ठीक है?
दूसरा यह तीसरा यह आई होप आप सबको समझ में
आ रहा होगा। ठीक है? चलिए काफी लोग
एक्साइटेड है। एक्साइटेड हैं आप लोग। अर
यू गाइस एक्साइटेड फॉर दिस सेशन? एक बार
बताइए मुझे। मजा आ रहा है?
मजा आ रहा है?
एक्साइटेड है सारे लोग काफी लोग एक्साइटेड
है। ठीक है? चलिए मैं भी एक्साइटेड हूं
क्योंकि ये क्लास का काफी डिमांड आ रहा था
और मुझे भी लेना ही था। या तो ये पूरा
सेटअप समझते जाइएगा। मैं ये गारंटी आपको
देता हूं कि अगर आप आज की इस क्लास में यह
सेटअप को और यह प्रोसेस को समझ लेंगे तो
आप इसको एग्जीक्यूट बहुत ईजीली कर पाएंगे।
अगर नहीं समझेंगे तो आपको कॉम्प्लेक्स
लगेगा। ठीक है?
ठीक है? समझ में आया? व्हाई डिड यू नॉट
यूज़ Microsoft sin इंस्टेड ऑफ स्प्लंक?
सेंटिनल यूज़ कर लो, स्प्लंक यूज़ कर लो,
वाज़ू यूज़ कर लो। व्हाटएवर यू वांट
प्लेटफार्म है। सेम प्लेटफार्म जो होता है
ना एसआईएम प्लेटफार्म वो आप कोई सा भी यूज़
कर लीजिए। स्प्लक, वाज़ू, सेंटिनल कोई सा
भी डज़ंट मैटर। स्प्लक इज़ हाइली यूज़्ड,
हाइली एक्सेप्ट एक्सेप्टेबल एट इंडस्ट्री
पर्पस। सेंट्रिनल भी है बट स्प्लंक इज
वाइडली स्प्रेड। तो मैं यहां पे स्प्लंक
यूज़ कर रहा हूं। ठीक है?
तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कुछ इस तरह
का सेटअप है यहां पे। अब देखो इसमें सेटअप
में क्या एक सीन क्या है कि यह जो काली
लinक्स है यह आपका
अटैकर है। यह आपका
अटैकर मशीन है। यह Windows जो है यह आपका
विक्टिम मशीन होगा। विक्टिम जिसके लॉग्स
जिस पर अटैक होंगे और लॉग्स करेक्ट कलेक्ट
होंगे जिसके ठीक है और यह जो युबू है आपका
यह आपका क्या है भैया ये आपका स्प्लंक है
जो सेम प्लेटफार्म में होता है सॉरी
एस आई
ई जो कि लॉग्स जहां पे लॉग्स आएंगे जहां
पे अब Windows के जो लॉग्स हैं वो इसमें
आएंगे
जो Windows के लॉग्स हैं वो सिम के पास
जाएंगे और काली से Windows पे अटैक किया
जाएगा। काली से Windows पे अटैक किया
जाएगा और Windows के जो लॉग्स हैं वो
स्प्लंक में जाएंगे और स्प्लंक पे आप फिर
लॉग्स को रीड करेंगे, एग्जामिन करेंगे,
अलर्ट्स आपको मिलेंगे। ये सब चीज़ जो
स्प्लंक का काम होता है। स्प्लंक की मैंने
अलग से डेडिकेटेड क्लास ली हुई है कि
स्प्लंक में कैसे क्या करते हैं वो आपको
पता ही है। तो मुझे मेरा यहां पे काम है
सेटअप करना। हां Windows में भी चल सकता
है। पहले भी मैंने बता रखा है Windows में
चला के। कुछ इस तरीके की पूरी ये सेटअप
होने वाली है। अब इसमें एक चीज़ आपको क्या
करना है कि ये जो तीनों मशीन है VMware के
अंदर में ये तीनों के तीनों एक होस्ट ओनली
सेटअप पे चलेगी। होस्ट ओनली नेटवर्क सेटअप
पे ये चलने वाला है। ठीक है? तो काली जो
है यह भी आपका किस पे चलेगा?
होस्ट ओनली नेटवर्क
सेकंड एज अ सेकंड नेटवर्क होगा। मैं आपको
यह लाइव करके जब दिखाऊंगा तो आपको
लाइक समझ में आ जाएगा कि मैं क्या बोल रहा
हूं।
यह भी होस्ट ओनली नेटवर्क पे होगी। यह भी
होस्ट ओनली नेटवर्क पे होगा। और यह भी
आपका होस्ट ओनली नेटवर्क पे ही चलेगा।
इसका मतलब क्या है? देखिए, दो नेटवर्क
अपर्स हम इस सेटअप में यूज़ करने वाले हैं।
वी आर गोइंग टू यूज़ टू नेटवर्क सेटअप्स इन
दिस पर्टिकुलर अ लैब। एक जो नेटवर्क होगा
वो आपका नेट होगा। नेट इसलिए ताकि इंटरनेट
से कनेक्टिविटी बनी रहे। Windows से
कनेक्टिविटी बनी रहे। दूसरी आपकी होस्ट
ओनली होगी तीनों की ताकि ये तीनों मशीन
आपस में एक दूसरे से कनेक्ट कर पाएं। एक
दूसरे को पिंग कर पाएं। ठीक है? ये काम
हमारा करना है हमें। अब यहां पे इन सब
चीजों के लिए कुछ चीजों की आपकी
रिक्वायरमेंट है वो आपको पहले पूरी करनी
पड़ेगी। सबसे पहले लैब सेटअप में
आपको कुछ आईएसओ फाइल्स चाहिए जो कि VMware
में आपको डालनी है। तो VMware में VMware
में ठीक है? लैब सेटअप क्या करना है? यह
देखिए। VMware में सबसे पहले आपको तो
चाहिए Ki Linux इंस्टॉल करनी है। Kali
Linux ISO के थ्रू। राइट?
उसके बाद Windows 10 आईएसo करनी है। उसके
बाद युb
सर्वर इंस्टॉल करनी है। एंड देन एक और चीज
चाहिए वो चाहिए स्प्लंक इंस्टॉल करना है।
एंड देन एक और चीज चाहिए स्प्लंक
फॉरवर्डर। यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर या फॉरवर्डर
बोल लो। स्प्लंक फॉरवर्डर। यह भी आपको
इंस्टॉल करनी है। यह सारी चीजें आपको एज अ
सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल करनी है। हालांकि इसको
यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर बोलते हैं। बट ऐसे
यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर लिख लो या जो भी बोलो
यहां पे स्प्लक यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर बोल लो
और यहां पे स्प्लंक एंटरप्राइजेस इंस्टॉल
करना है।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] ये
सारी चीजें आपको जो है वो इंस्टॉल करनी
है। इन सब चीज़ सभी लोग इधर ध्यान दीजिए
अभी के लिए यहां के। अब इन सब चीजों को
इंस्टॉल सारी चीजें इंस्टॉल करने में तो
काफी समय लग जाएगा। काफी टाइम लग जाएगा।
मैं आपको बस तरीका बता देता हूं। कैसे
इंस्टॉल करना है, क्या करना है वो सारी
चीजें ये सेटअप आपको करनी है। सो सबसे
पहले मैं VMware को ओपन करता हूं।
ठीक है? आई एम ओपनिंग द VMware। हियर वी
हैव ओपन द VMware हियर। ठीक है? अब यहां
VMware में यहां VMware के अंदर में मैंने
ये सारी चीजें इंस्टॉल करके रखी है। देखो
काली इंस्टॉलेशन है। बहुत इजी है। काली
इंस्टॉल करना ऑलमोस्ट सबको आता होगा। नहीं
भी आता तो ट्यूटोरियल है। सिंपल काली को
इंस्टॉल करें। अब मैं काली की इंस्टॉलेशन
नहीं बताने वाला हूं। क्योंकि अगर मैं
इंस्टॉलेशन बताने जाऊं एक-एक कीस की तो
फिर इसमें चारप क्लासेस अलग से जोड़ लीजिए
और वो कोई मतलब नहीं बनता है। दिस इज़ एन
एसओसी क्लास नॉट काली इंस्टॉलेशन क्लास।
सो काली इंस्टॉल होना चाहिए आपका। Windows
10 जो है एज अ विक्टिम इंस्टॉल होना चाहिए
और Ubts जो है ubt सर्वर वो इंस्टॉल होना
चाहिए। मैं आपको बस इसकी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन आपको
बताऊंगा और कहां से कैसे इंस्टॉल करना है
वो मैं आपको बताऊंगा। देखो
इफ यू वांट टू इंस्टॉल काली एथ्स बहुत
सिंपल है। काली डाउनलोड सर्च करना है
आपको। गेट काली काली एक ऑफिशियल वेबसाइट
है। इंस्टॉलर इमेज पे आनी है। एंड यहां पे
आपको इंस्टॉलर वाली जो इमेज है इसको
डाउनलोड करना है और आपको अपने VMZ में
इसको इंस्टॉल कर लेनी है। एज सिंपल एज दैट
Kali गेट्स इंस्टॉल। अब आते हैं Windows
10 के इंस्टॉलेशन पे। Windows 10 कहां से
इंस्टॉल होगा? तो भैया यहां पे डाउनलोड
Windows 10 सर्च कर लीजिएगा।
यहां पे देखेंगे डाउनलोड Windows 10 डेस्क
इमेज फाइल वाला ऑप्शन आएगा ऑफिशियल यहां
पर आइएगा। अब यहां पर आप आएंगे ना तो यहां
पर यह बोलेगा कि Windows 10 के इंस्टॉलेशन
आईएसओ अगर चाहिए आपको जो कि आपके VMware
के लिए रिक्वायरमेंट है तो आपको मीडिया
क्रिएशन टूल डाउनलोड करना पड़ेगा। फिर
पेनड्राइव में मतलब वो फिर वो आईएसओ बना
के डाउनलोड करना पड़ेगा ऐसा। बट हमें ऐसा
नहीं करने की जरूरत नहीं है। अब यहां पे
ये बोल रहा है मीडिया क्रिएशन टूल डाउनलोड
होगा। जब ये डाउनलोड आप करोगे ना यहां पे
डाउनलोड तो देखो क्या डाउनलोड होगा ये? यह
डाउनलोड होगा मीडिया क्रिएशन टूल ना किएo
Windows 10 की तो हमें यह नहीं करनी यार
हम इसका शॉर्टकट इसका एक वे अराउंड निकाल
तरीका यूज करेंगे हम क्या करेंगे राइट
क्लिक करेंगे यहां पे इंस्पेक्ट पे जाएंगे
इंस्पेक्ट पे इसी पेज पे इंस्पेक्ट पे जब
जाएंगे यहां पे जाएंगे ये जो रिस्पांसिबल
है ना डिवाइस टूलबार रिस्पांसिव वाला
टूलबार ये ये यहां पे इसको हम टॉगल कर
इनेबल कर देंगे इनेबल किया अब ये इनेबल कर
दिया हमने ये मोबाइल व्यू टाइप आ गया
थोड़ा सा वैसे टाइप का यहां पे आ गया अब
इस पेज को हम एक एक बार रीलोड कर देंगे।
रीलोड करेंगे। अब जैसे ही रीलोड करेंगे,
दैट्स इट। इसको क्लोज़ कर देंगे इस टूलबार
को। अब यहां पे नीचे की तरफ आएंगे। नीचे
की तरफ आएंगे। अब आपके पास ऑप्शन आ जाएगा
कि ये आईएसओ डाउनलोड कीजिए Windows 10 का।
एंड यहां पे एडिशन आपको सेलेक्ट करने का आ
जाएगा। Windows 10 मल्टी एडिशन यानी
मल्टीपल Windows 10 Pro सब कुछ इसमें
रहेगा। ये सेलेक्ट किया आपने। एंड यहां पे
आपको कंफर्म करने का ऑप्शन आएगा। जैसे ही
आप कंफर्म करेंगे, यह वैलिडेट करेगा
रिक्वेस्ट को। अब यह लैंग्वेज सेलेक्ट
करने का बोलेगा, तो यूनाइटेड स्टेट
सेलेक्ट कर लीजिएगा। कंफर्म कर दीजिएगा।
कंफर्म कर दीजिएगा इसकी जो आईएसओ है
डाउनलोड करने का 32 बिट 64 बिट आपके
सिस्टम आर्किटेक्चर के अकॉर्डिंग जैसे
आपका 64 बिट है तो 64 बिट 32 बिट है 32
बिट क्लिक कीजिएगा एंड यहां पे डायरेक्ट
Windows 10 की जो आईएसओ फाइल है वो
डाउनलोड होना यहां पे स्टार्ट हो जाएगी जो
कि ऑलमोस्ट आपको 5.7 GB की होगी। ठीक है?
आईएसओ जिसका यूज़ करके आप Windows 10
इंस्टॉल करेंगे VMware के अंदर में। मैं
यहां पे ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल मतलब डाउनलोड कर
चुका हूं। आई डोंट नीड इट। सो आई एम
कैंसिलिंग इट। ठीक है? क्योंकि इसमें
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बहुत फिर
टाइम जाता आईएसओ फाइल आपको चाहिए कि आप
VMware में Windows को इंस्टॉल कर पाओ या
काली को इंस्टॉल कर पाओ। Ubtू को इंस्टॉल
कर पाओ। यू नीड एन आईएसओ फाइल। वही आईएसओ
फाइल की यहां पे बात हो रही है। अब यहां
पे अब आपको Ubtu इंस्टॉल करना है। उबू तो
उबू का सर्वर वर्जन जो है वो आपको इंस्टॉल
करना पड़ेगा। VMware के अंदर में यहां पे
डेस्कटॉप नहीं। तो Ubuntू के लिए क्या
करना है यहां पे? सिंपल उबू
डाउनलोड अगेन वही सेम चीज उबू यहां पे
आपको करना है उबू सर्वर डाउनलोड ये वाली
उबू सर्वर डाउनलोड पे जाना है अब यहां पे
आप आएंगे तो यहां पे आपको दिखेगा उबू का
सर्वर वर्जन लेटेस्ट Intel MD 64 के लिए
यहां पे डाउनलोड 3GB का आ रहा है यहां पे
आप इसको सिंपल डाउनलोड पे क्लिक कर
दीजिएगा एंड यहां पे आपका जो सर्वर वर्जन
है वह डाउनलोड होना स्टार्ट हो जाएगा
देखिए अभी यह डाउनलोड शुड स्टार्ट इन
बैकग्राउंड। यह देखिए उबू का यहां पे सर्व
वर्जन जो है आईएसओ फाइल यहां पे डाउनलोड
होना स्टार्ट हो चुका है। अगेन आई हैव
ऑलरेडी डाउनलोडेड इट। सो आई डोंट नीड इट
टू डाउनलोड इट। ठीक है? तो यहां पे मैंने
डाउनलोड कैंसिल कर लिया। अब ये तीनों जब
हो गई हो जाएगी आपकी उसके बाद इसको आपको
इंस्टॉल करना है। ठीक है? अब इन सारे
इंस्टॉलेशन में ये जो सारा इंस्टॉलेशन
प्रोसेस हुआ है इसमें Ubtu का जो
इंस्टॉलेशन है वो यूई इंस्टॉलेशन मतलब
सिंपल नॉर्मल सा जैसे काली इंस्टॉल आप
करते हैं ऐसे ही untu सर्वर इंस्टॉल होगा
वैसे ही आपका Windows 10 इंस्टॉल होगा।
कुछ भी नहीं करना है। बहुत सिंपल सा तरीका
है। ठीक है? अब यहां पे Windows 10 जब
इंस्टॉल आप कर रहे हैं तो Windows 10
इंस्टॉलेशन के इस प्रोसेस में आपको
सेलेक्ट करना है Windows 10 का प्रो
वर्जन। Windows 10 Pro वहां पे ऑप्शन आपको
मिलेगा Windows 10 Pro। मैं आपको इसका एक
ओवरव्यू दे देता हूं। हालांकि मैं ऑलरेडी
इंस्टॉल कर चुका हूं। बट मैं स्टिल आई विल
बी टेलिंग यू ऑल द थिंग्स। जैसे मैं यहां
पे न्यू वर्चुअल मशीन करूंगा। मान लो
Windows 10 हमें इंस्टॉल करना है तो
टिपिकल करते हैं। नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक करते
हैं। यहां पे Windows 10 का ISO जो
डाउनलोड किया आपने Windows 10 इसको
सेलेक्ट कर लीजिएगा। यह Windows 10
डिटेक्ट हो जाएगा। ईजी इंस्टॉल होगा। मतलब
आराम से इंस्टॉलेशन ये सिंपल प्रोसेस में
हो जाएगी। नेक्स्ट कीजिएगा। Windows का
प्रोडक्ट की मांगेगा। मत दीजिएगा। कोई भी
प्रोडक्ट की आपके पास है नहीं। यहां पे
Windows [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] का
एडिशन चूज़ कर लीजिएगा। तो Windows 10 Pro
सेलेक्ट कीजिएगा। फुल नेम आपको जो भी
डालना है
हेलो। पासवर्ड आप डाल दीजिएगा। व्हाटएवर
पासवर्ड यू वांट टू एंटर। पासवर्ड डाल
दीजिएगा। नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक करना है। ठीक
है? यहां पे वी आएगा एक कि वी डिड नॉट
एंटर द प्रोडक्ट की। कोई बात नहीं यार यस
कर देते हैं। अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आ रहा है Windows 10। ठीक है भैया। तो मैं
यहां पर नाम दे देता हूं। Windows कुछ भी
दे दीजिए आप नाम। नेक्स्ट पर क्लिक करते
हैं। अब यहां पे ये डिस्क साइज मांगेगा कि
कितना डिस्क स्पेस होगा। तो मैं मान लो
यहां पे अ 30 विंडो हां Windows के डिस्क
साइज का जब भी आए तो 50 GB के आसपास ही आप
इसकी डिस्क साइज रखिएगा। इससे ज्यादा कम
डिस्क साइज मत दीजिएगा। अदरवाइज़ Windows
जो है आपकी सही से काम
नहीं करेगी। ठीक है? तो 50 GB डिस्क साइज़
आप इसको दे दीजिएगा यहां पे। एंड आई थिंक
मेरे पास अभी डिस्क साइज़ अवेलेबिलिटी
कितनी है यहां पे? 93B फ्री है। चलिए फिर
मैं इसको तो डिलीट कर ही दूंगा। तो 50 GB
दे दीजिएगा। इसको यहां पे नेक्स्ट पे
क्लिक कर दीजिएगा। एंड यहां पे अब यहां पे
कस्टमाइज हार्डवेयर का ऑप्शन आएगा। ठीक
है? तो कस्टमाइज हार्डवेयर में अभी सब कुछ
सेम रहने देते हैं। और यहां पे आप फिनिश
कर दीजिएगा। फिनिश जब करेंगे तो ये डिस्क
क्रिएट करना स्टार्ट करेगा। Windows 10 के
लिए क्रिएटिंग डिस्क इसको होने दीजिएगा
आप। क्रिएट हो होता रहेगा ये। एंड उसके
बाद जो है यहां पे Windows 10 की
इंस्टॉलेशन आप स्टार्ट कर पाएंगे। ठीक है?
लेट्स सी। लेट्स वेट फॉर द रिस्क क्रिएशन
देन वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग।
ओके काफी मजा आने वाला है आज तो अभी तो
अभी नेटवर्क कॉन्फ़िगरेशन भी करनी है गाइस
हमें। सो उसका भी वेट कीजिए।
डेस्कटॉप वर्जन डेस्कटॉप यूज़ के लिए है।
मल्टीमीडिया और बहुत सी चीजें हैं। थोड़ा
हैवी यूज़ के लिए। हैवी साइज वॉर सब सर्वर
वर्जन है थोड़ा सर्वर्स अ
मेनली सर्वर्स के कॉन्फ़िगरेशन और इन सब
चीजों में यूज़ आप कर सकते हैं।
मल्टीमीडिया सपोर्ट नहीं होता ज्यादा।
सीएलआई वगैरह सीएलआई का वो मिल जाता है
आपको। पूरा कमांड लाइन मिल जाता है।
इंटरफ़ेस मिल जाता है।
ओके। सो हियर इज़ सत्यम सत्यम प्रियदर्शी
इस सेइंग आई एम टेकिंग अ पेड कोर्स इन
सोशल मीडिया बट अ सोशल एनालिस्ट
सोशल एनालिस्ट या कुछ और बोल रहे हैं आप
सोशल एनालिस्ट क्या होता है
ओके मैं एक पेड कोर्स कर कर रहा हूं एसओसी
की बट यह वाली प्लेलिस्ट मुझे एक शॉक
एनालिस्ट ने रिकमेंड करी है। वाओ क्या बात
है।
क्या बात है। बहुत बढ़िया। थैंक यू वेरी
मच।
इतना अच्छा सुनने को जब मिलता है तो मजा
आता है। मैं आप लोगों को भी दिखा देता हूं
इन्होंने जो बोला है। और यह खुद ही बोलते
हैं सभी लोग। यह देखिए मैं एक पेड कोर्स
कर रहा हूं शॉक की। बट यह वाली प्लेलिस्ट
मुझे एक शॉक एनालिस्ट ने रिकमेंड करी है।
डेली आपकी क्लास ले रहा हूं। अभी सिक्स्थ
लेक्चर पे हूं। प्रीमियम कंटेंट है आपका।
थैंक यू वेरी मच। सत्यम प्रियदर्शी। आई
होप कि आपको
बढ़िया ही लगता रहेगा हमेशा एंड प्रीमियम
क्वालिटी आपको मिलती रहेगी हमेशा।
चलिए कम से कम 16GB कम से कम 16GB रखिए तब
ये ठीक है। अब ये Windows 10 की जो सेटअप
है वो आपकी स्टार्ट होगी। आप देखिए यहां
पे
Windows 10 की यहां पे सेटअप आपकी स्टार्ट
होगी। अब Windows 10 का जो पूरा सेटअप
होता है वैसे ही सेटअप करना है और Windows
को इंस्टॉल कर लेना है। दैट्स इट। और कुछ
भी आपको नहीं करना है। एंड Windows 10 विल
बी इंस्टॉल्ड। फिलहाल के लिए मुझे यह
ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड है मेरा। तो मैं इसको
पावर ऑफ शट डाउन कर देता हूं। मतलब पावर
ऑफ कर देता हूं। एंड इस Windows को मैं
डिलीट कर देता हूं। क्योंकि Windows
ऑलरेडी मेरा अ लाइक ऑलरेडी है। मतलब
ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड है। तो मैं यहां पर
रिमूव करता हूं।
मैनेज डिलीट फ्रॉम डिस्क कर देते हैं ताकि
स्पेस थोड़ा बच जाएगा हमारा या आई होप कि
स्पेस है अभी भी
हम
ठीक है ठीक है तो हमारा ये Windows का
इंस्टॉलेशन पार्ट डन हो गया। अब यहां पे
U12 का इंस्टॉलेशन की पार्ट की बात करूं
तो U12 में इंस्टॉल करने के लिए सिंपल
न्यू डिस्क कर दीजिएगा। नेक्स्ट कीजिएगा।
अगेन यहां पे आएo U12 वाला सेलेक्ट कर
लीजिएगा। U12 सर्वर है। यह ऑलरेडी डिटेक्ट
होगा। नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक कर दीजिएगा। U1 64
बिट है। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
U12 कर देंगे। यहां पे नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक
करेंगे। यहां पे डिस्क साइज 20GB है। आप
इसको थोड़ा बढ़ा दीजिएगा। मैं यहां पे Ub2
के डिस्क साइज की बात करूं तो मैं 40 या
40GB बोलूंगा करने को। तो आप 40GB के
आसपास कर दीजिएगा। यहां पे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सेलेक्ट एज अ
सिंगल डिस्क। नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक कर दीजिए।
एंड यहां पे फिर से फिनिश कर देंगे। जैसे
ही फिनिश करेंगे U1 का इंस्टॉलेशन वाला जो
स्क्रीन है वो आ जाएगा और कुछ इस तरीके से
U1 क्योंकि ये सर्वर एडिशन है गाइस तो
आपको यहां पे एक सीएलआई के थ्रू
इंस्टॉलेशन करनी पड़ेगी U12 की तो कुछ इस
तरीके का आपको यहां पे इंटरफ़ेस देखने को
मिलेगा ये U1 की इंस्टॉलेशन स्क्रीन है आप
देखते जाइए सभी लोग मैं आपको हर एक चीज
बता दे रहा हूं ताकि बाद में आपको दिक्कत
ना हो किसी तरह की
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
आप [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सभी लोग
देखिए
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
हम
ये इंस्टॉलेशन मैं उबू की इंस्टॉलेशन
थोड़ी आपको चीजें बता देता हूं क्योंकि
इसमें कुछ चीजें हैं जो आपको ध्यान रखनी
है। अ सो इट्स गेटिंग
इट्स गेटिंग द इंस्टॉलेशन ऑप्शंस। अब
देखिए यहां पे आपको पहले तो ऑडियो
लैंग्वेज इंग्लिश सेलेक्ट करनी है। उसके
बाद कीबोर्ड कॉन्फ़िगरेशन सेम है। सब कुछ
यहां पे आपका सेम है। यहां पे डन पे क्लिक
कर देना है। उसके बाद यहां पे ऑप्शन आ रहा
है कौन सा सेलेक्ट आपको कौन सा यूज़ करना
है? Uban टू सर्वर इंस्टॉल करना है। सर्वर
मिनिमाइज्ड इंस्टॉल करनी है या कौन सा
एडिशनल ड्राइवर वगैरह? तो सर्वर वन टू
सर्वर पे ऑलरेडी एक्स का साइन है। एक्स का
साइन है मतलब यही सिलेक्टेड है। तो हमें
यही रखना है। तो नीचे डाउन एरो की से डन
पे आएंगे और एंटर कर देंगे। उसके बाद ये
आपका लाइक नेटवर्क कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डिटेक्ट कर
रहा है। इसको जैसा है वैसा रहने देते हैं।
डन पे क्लिक कर देंगे। यहां पे प्रॉक्सी
एड्रेस बोल रहा है करने को। तो हमें
प्रॉक्सी एड्रेस कुछ डालना नहीं है। कोई
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर से हम कनेक्टेड नहीं है।
तो डन कर देंगे। अब यहां पे आ रहा है कि
ये कुछ अपडेट वगैरह है लाइक
कुछ अपडेट वगैरह का यहां पे इफ यू सी एन
अल्टरनेटिव मिरर फॉर वन टू एंटर इट्स
डिटेल्स हियर तो ये अपना आर्काइव जो है
मिरर कॉन्फ़िगरेशन वो कर रहा है तो इसको
करने देंगे इसके लिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
ये अपना कर लेगा रीडिंग पैकेज लिस्ट सब
कुछ इसने कर दिया है। इट्स ऑल डन डन पे
क्लिक कर देंगे। यहां पे सारा ये डिटेल्स
दे देगा कि ये डेव एसडीए जो है वो बन रही
है। 40 GB की बन रही है। एलवीएम आपका बन
रहा है। सेटअप ये एक एलवीएम ग्रुप का
पार्ट होगा। लॉजिक वॉल्यूम मैनेजर जो होते
हैं जिसको आप एक्सटेंड बढ़ा घटा सकते हैं।
ऐसा करके अपने अकॉर्डिंग रीसाइज़ कर सकते
हैं। ये फ्लैक्सिबिलिटी देती है। जैसे
डिस्क साइज़ होती है ना, तो अनएलोकेटेड
स्पेस से ये बढ़ जाती है। तो, हमें गाइडेड
पार्टीशन यूज़ ही करना है। तो, हम गाइडेड
पार्टीशन यूज़ करेंगे। डन पे क्लिक कर
देंगे। यहां पूरी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन आ जाएगी।
क्या-क्या बन रहा है? आप देख सकते हैं
यहां पे कि एक फ्री स्पेस 19 GB है। साइज
37GB की टोटल बन रही है। फ्री स्पेस उसमें
19 GB है यहां पे। आप ऊपर में जाएंगे तो
देखेंगे और यहां पे आप डन पे क्लिक कर
दीजिए। तो यह पूछा है आर यू शो वांट टू
कंटिन्यू मतलब इंस्टॉलेशन प्रोसेस स्टार्ट
करना चाहते हैं तो कंटिन्यू कर दीजिए। एंड
यहां पे अब आपका नाम पूछ रहा है। तो मैं
नाम जैसे मैं कुछ भी नाम दे देता हूं।
नितेश सिंह सर्वर नेम पूछ रहा है। सर्वर
नेम में आप कुछ भी दे सकते हैं। व्हाटएवर
सर्वर यू वांट नेम तो डिफ्रॉनिक्स अ
स्प्लक
सर्वर यह मैंने डाल दिया। यूजरनेम स्प्लंक
डिफ्रॉनिक्स कर दिया आपने। पासवर्ड
कुछ भी आप पासवर्ड डाल दीजिए यहां पे।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
स्प्लक डिफ्रॉनिक्स यूजरनेम है। पासवर्ड
मैंने वैसे ही क्वाटी डाल दिया है। मैं
यहां पे डन पे क्लिक कर देता हूं। अब यहां
पे आ रहा है कि क्या आप UN Pro को इनेबल
करना चाहते हैं? तो जरूरत नहीं है UT Pro
इनेबल करना। कंटिन्यू कर दीजिए। यहां पे
ऑप्शन दे रहा है कि इंस्टॉल ओपन एसएसएच
सर्वर। तो इसको जरूर टिक करना है। इसको
जरूर यहां पे क्रॉस करना है। तो एंटर
कीजिए। यहां पे क्रॉस हो जाएगा। मतलब वो
टिक हो गया है। अब यहां पे नीचे आके डन
करेंगे। मतलब इंस्टॉल एसएसएच सर्वर को
इंस्टॉल कर देगा। इनमें जो जो जरूरत की
चीज़ है वो ऑलरेडी सही है। कुछ नहीं करना
है। डन पे क्लिक कर देना है। एंड दैट्स
इट। इसके बाद आपकी U12 की जो U1 की
इंस्टॉलेशन है वो आपकी स्टार्ट हो जाएगी।
आप देख सकते होंगे ऊपर में आपको
इंस्टॉलिंग सिस्टम का ऑप्शन मिल रहा दिख
रहा होगा। ये सिस्टम इंस्टॉलेशन स्टार्ट
हो चुकी है। उंटी जो है उबू जो सर्वर है
जो आपको वो स्टार्ट हो जाएगी। बस यहीं तक
था। आपका सीएलआई आपका आ जाएगा। जो कमांड
लाइन इंटरफ़ेस होता है वो आपकी आ जाएगी। बस
इतना ही था। इसके बाद कुछ नहीं करना है।
मैं इसको भी फिलहाल के लिए पावर ऑफ कर
देता हूं।
क्योंकि ऑलरेडी हमारा इंस्टॉल्ड है। तो वी
विल नॉट वेस्ट अ टाइम ओवर इट। ठीक है? हो
गया। इसको भी मैं यहां से डिलीट कर देता
हूं। क्योंकि हमारा ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड है
ऊपर। चलिए अब ये सारा चीज़ तो हो गया। अब
आते हैं एक्चुअल कॉन्फ़िगरेशन पे जो हमारी
स्प्लंक के लिए सिम सॉक लैब के लिए चाहिए।
अब ये तीनों चीज़ हो गई। अब हमें यहां पे
क्या करना है वो मैं आपको बताता हूं। अब
हमारा जो ये तीनों मशीन है काली,
Windows 10 एंड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] वन टू सर्वर।
अब इस तीनों की नेटवर्क कॉन्फ़िगरेशन हमें
क्रिएट करनी है। क्या करनी है वो मैं आपको
बता देता हूं। काली में जाना है। काली के
एडिट वर्चुअल मशीन सेटिंग्स पे आना है या
सेटिंग्स में जाना है। यहां पे आपको कुछ
चीजें दिखेंगी। बाय डिफॉल्ट आपका सिर्फ यह
नेटवर्क अपर पहला एक रहेगा। एक नेटवर्क
अप्टर आपका रहेगा यहां पे नेट पे। नेट पे
चलिए मैं इसको ना एक काम करता हूं। आई एम
गोइंग टू डू वन थिंग। आई एम गोइंग टू
रिसेट इट अ ताकि मैं फिर से आपको बता
सकूं।
मैं फटाफट रिसेट कर देता हूं तीनों का।
ताकि मैं आपको वह चीजें क्रिएट करके बता
सकूं।
एंड यू विल
से इट
हां जी हो गया। अब आपको क्या करना है? इन
तीनों मशीन का नेटवर्क अपॉप्टर सेटिंग
नेटवर्क सेटिंग्स को चेंज करनी है। काली
में जाना है। एडिट वर्चुअल मशीन यहां से
आप जा सकते हैं। या तो काली पे राइट क्लिक
करके सेटिंग्स पे जा सकते हैं। सब एक ही
है। या तो काली को सेलेक्ट किया है। वीएम
पे जाना है। सेटिंग पे जाना है। सब एक ही
ऑप्शन है। इस पे जाएंगे। अब यहां पे आप
देखेंगे कि एक सिंगल आपके भी सिस्टम में
जब आप वीएमवेयर में करोगे ये सब काम तो
यहां पे नेटवर्क अपर एक सिंगल अप्टर होगा
बाय डिफॉल्ट जिसमें आपका नैट सेलेक्ट हो
सकता है ब्रिज सेलेक्ट हो सकता है वॉस कुछ
भी हो सकता है राइट हमें इसे नेट करना है
ताकि यह होस्ट से कनेक्ट हो सके इंटरनेट
को इंटरनेट शेयर कर सके इंटरनेट मतलब यूज़
कर सके तो हमें पहला एक नेट अपर सेलेक्ट
करके रखना है दैट्स इट फाइन लेकिन हमें एक
और अप्टर यहां क्रिएट करनी है नेटवर्क
अप्टर जो कि होगी होस्ट ओनली। होस्ट ओनली
अप्टर क्या होता है? जैसे आप तीनों जो यह
मशीन है काली, Windows 10 और Uban 2 इन
तीनों का होस्ट ओनली जब आप नेटवर्क कर
देते हैं तो ये तीनों मशीन आपस में बात
करेगी और बाहर की दुनिया से उसको कोई मतलब
नहीं रहेगा। तो पूरी सेफ रहेगी ये बाहर की
दुनिया से पूरी सेफ रहेगी। और नैट कर दिया
आपने तो आपका होस्ट मशीन जो ये मेरा
Windows है जिसमें मैंने VMware डाला है।
इसमें सब कुछ डाला है। Windows इसको रीच
आउट कर पाएगा। बाकी और कोई रीच आउट इसको
नहीं कर पाएगा। सिर्फ होस्ट रीच आउट कर
पाएगा। ठीक है? नेट में अब देखो यहां पे
बाहर से मतलब इंटरनेट एक्सेस कर पाएगा।
मतलब ये इंटरनेट एक्सेस कर सकता है। इसको
कोई एक्सेस नहीं कर सकता है। आपका नेट में
ऐसा हो जाएगा। तो हमें एक नैट रखना है और
दूसरा एक और अप्टर ऐड करनी है। ऐड ऑप्शन
पे जाके और यहां नेटवर्क अपर सेलेक्ट करना
है। फिनिश करनी है। तो यह नेटवर्क अपॉप्टर
टू आ गया यहां पे काली के लिए। अब इसमें
आपको होस्ट ओनली सेलेक्ट करनी है। होस्ट
ओनली। होस्ट ओनली कर लिया।
एंड यहां पर ओके कर देना है। बस काली की
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डन। अब यहां पर Windows 10 पे
चलना है। सेम एडिट वर्चुअल मशीन सेटिंग
सेम यहां पे नेटवर्क अपर टू यहां पे।
अच्छा यहां दो थे क्या? चलो यहां पे दो
थे। इसमें भी ऐसे ही ऐड कर लेना है। सेकंड
होस्ट ओनली करके ओके कर देना है। फिर उबू
पे चलना है। एडिट वर्चुअल मशीन सेटिंग।
यहां पे सेम ऐड करना है। यहां पे नेटवर्क
अप्टर करना है। यहां पे फ़िनिश करनी है।
नेटवर्क अपर टू पे। यहां पे होस्ट ऑल नहीं
करना है। ओके कर देना है। बस दैट्स इट। अब
देखो
यहां पे अब इन तीनों में आईपी जो है उन
तीनों की जो आईपी मिलेगी वो किस रेंज की
मिलेगी यह मैं आपको बता देता हूं। जैसे अब
होस्ट ओनली अप्टर का आईपी रेंज क्या है?
वो भी आप देख लीजिए। आप वीएम पे एडिट पे
जाएंगे। वर्चुअल नेटवर्क एडिटर पे जाएंगे।
लोडिंग नेटवर्क कॉन्फ़िगरेशन आ रही है। तो
देखेंगे आप कि होस्ट ओनली जो अप्टर है
इसका IP रेंज है 192 168.232.0
यानी इन तीनों की IP का फर्स्ट तीन मतलब
जो फर्स्ट तीन ऑक्टेट जो नंबर होगा या
फील्ड होगा वो होगी 192 168.232
और उसके बाद डॉट के बाद अलग-अलग आईपीस
होंगी। इन तीनों का ठीक है? यह IP होंगी।
चलिए बढ़िया है। अब हम क्या करते हैं?
हमारा काम शुरू करते हैं। जो हमारा मेन
काम है उसको हम स्टार्ट करते हैं। तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां तक सब हां
पहले मुझे बता दीजिए। यहां तक सभी को समझ
में आया? एवरीथिंग इज क्लियर टिल हियर। आई
एम सीइंग द मोबाइल चैट बॉक्स। प्लीज मुझे
बताइए।
एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी नो।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
16 GB RAM नहीं है तो बहुत मुश्किल आएगा।
बहुत मुश्किल आएगा। 16 GB RAM नहीं है।
देखो यहां पे RAM की यूटिलाइजेशन देखो ना।
हां, अब रैम और डिस्क की मैं चीजें बता
देता हूं। मैंने काली को 4GB की मेमोरी दी
है। दो प्रोसेसर काउंट दिया है। यहां पे
40 GB की हार्ड डिस्क दी है। 2 में मैंने
40 GB की हार्ड डिस्क दी है। दो प्रोसेसर
अकाउंट दी है। 4 GB रैम दिया है। Windows
10 में मैंने 4 GB रैम दिया है। दो
प्रोसेसर अकाउंट दिया है। 50 GB की हार्ड
डिस्क दी है। तो मेरा रैम यूटिलाइजेशन भी
काफी ज्यादा हो रहा होगा। मैं टास्क
मैनेजर में आपको दिखाऊंगा। अभी जब यह
चलेंगे तब अभी तो नहीं हो रहा होगा। मैं
अभी टास्क मैनेजर में यहां पे आप मेमोरी
जो है अभी 32% मेमोरी यूज़ हो रही है। यह
देख रहे होंगे आप यहां मेमोरी में आपको
32% दिख रही है। ये देखो यहां पे मेमोरी
यूज़ में 32% अभी जब मैं ये ऑन करूंगा सब
चीजें तब आपको दिखाऊंगा कि ये कितना
मेमोरी यूज़ हो रहा है। क्या यूज़ हो रहा है
तब देखना आप। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके ये सारी चीज़ हो गई। चलिए अब जो है
हमारा नेक्स्ट प्रोसेस जो है वो आ जाता
है। एक उबंटू हमने क्रिएट कर लिया। हमने
सारे फाइल्स हमने जो भी हमें डाउनलोड करने
थे जो भी चीजें हमें करनी थी वो सारी
चीजें कर ली। अब हमें एक चीज और डाउनलोड
करनी है वो है दैट इज द स्प्लंक
जो इटसेल्फ स्प्लक टूल है वो हमें डाउनलोड
करना है। स्प्लंक एंटरप्राइज़ जो है उसे
हमें डाउनलोड करनी है। तो चलिए हमें
स्प्लंक एंटरप्राइज़ डाउनलोड करने की देखते
हैं कैसे होगा। तो करना है स्प्लंक
डाउनलोड ये करना है।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
स्प्लंक पे चलेंगे
और यहां पे आएगा लॉगिन का ऑप्शन। यह आपके
लॉग इन का ऑप्शन आ रहा है। लॉग इन पे
क्लिक कर देंगे। यहां पे आपको पहले अकाउंट
क्रिएट करनी पड़ेगी। तो बिज़नेस ईमेल आईडी
जो भी डालना है आपको डाल दीजिए। 60 डेज का
फ्री ट्रायल वैसे मिल जाता है। यहां पे
कोई सी भी ईमेल आईडी कंटिन्यू कीजिए। आपकी
डाउनलोड हो जाएगी। मतलब बिज़नेस ईमेल और
लॉग इन कर लीजिए। लॉग इन करने के बाद आप
डाउनलोड जो है वो कर सकते हैं। तो मैं
यहां पे लॉग इन करता हूं। यहां पे आ रहा
है ईमेल आपका बताइए। तो मैं यहां पे ईमेल
डाल देता हूं।
आई एम एंटरिंग द ईमेल। उसके बाद मैं यहां
पे पासवर्ड डालूंगा। सो, लेट्स एंटर द
पासवर्ड हियर। कहां गया भाई?
आई होप कि यह पासवर्ड सही डाला है मैंने।
अ नहीं तो फिर से रिसेट करना पड़ेगा।
लेट्स सी।
या
सही। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो ये
आपका आ गया। ठीक है? अब ये जो स्प्लंक है,
हमें यह स्प्लंक हमें उबू जो मशीन है,
इसमें इंस्टॉल करनी है। मैंने आपको पूरा
आर्किटेक्चर बताया था पहले इस पे उबू के
अंदर यह स्प्लक इंस्टॉल करनी है। स्प्लंक
विल बी इंस्टॉल्ड ऑन द उबंटू सर्वर। तो
पहले हम उबू सर्वर को स्टार्ट कर लेते
हैं। पावर ऑन द उबन टू सर्वर लेट्स पावर
ऑन।
ठीक है? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
वी आर पावरिंग ऑन द उबन टू सर्वर।
यहां पर स्टार्ट हो रहा है।
यह सर्वर वर्जन है तो आपको ग्राफिक्स कुछ
ज्यादा कुछ नहीं मिलेगा नहीं। आपको सीएलआई
के थ्रू सब कुछ करना है।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
तो यहां पे सर्वर वर्जन हमारा स्टार्ट हो
चुका है। अब यह भैया जो है यह बोलते हैं
कि भैया मुझे यू सॉरी एक सेकंड थोड़ा कुछ
यह बड़ा नहीं होगा क्या?
ओके आई थिंक यह नहीं बड़ा होगा। पहले यहां
पर लॉग इन करना है। तो मैं लॉग इन यहां पर
कर देता हूं। आई थिंक इट्स डेफोनिक्स।
और पासवर्ड में मेरे ख्याल से जो मैं सोच
रहा हूं वही होगा। आई डोंट नो। हां, लॉग
इन तो हो गया। चलो अब ये बड़ा होगा क्या?
ये तो भाई बड़ा नहीं होने वाला है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आई होप यू ऑल
कैन सी द स्क्रीन। आपको ये दिख रहा है
क्या गाइस? टर्मिनल सबको दिख रहा है ना?
एक बार मुझे बता दीजिए एक बार कंफर्म
कीजिए। यू ऑल कैन सी द आप ज़ूम भी कर सकते
हैं। वैसे तो अपने सिस्टम पे या मतलब अपने
मोबाइल पे अगर आप देख रहे हैं या कुछ भी।
यू कैन ज़ूम इन पिंच एंड ज़ूम। तो आपको शायद
दिख जाएगा। तो मुझे एक बार बताइए आप सब
देख पा रहे हैं क्या ये जो कमांड्स या जो
भी चीजें हैं क्योंकि आई
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] डोंट थिंक कि
इसमें मैं कुछ इसको ज्यादा बड़ा कर पाऊंगा।
थैंक यू कॉफी गेम गेमरी। थैंक यू वेरी मच।
दिख रहा है सबको? ठीक है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब यहां पे
मैंने अपना लॉग इन कर लिया। जब यह लॉग इन
कहां से आया? यह लॉग इन आप जब उबू इंस्टॉल
करेंगे तो वहां पे ही जो यूजरनेम और
पासवर्ड बनवाया गया था आपसे वही यूजर
पासवर्ड से यहां पे आपको लॉग इन करना है।
तो मैंने यहां पे लॉग इन कर लिया है। अब
हमें यहीं पे स्प्लंक को इंस्टॉल करना है।
यू हैव टू इंस्टॉल स्प्ल हियर ओनली वी हैव
टू यहां पे। तो इंस्टॉल कैसे करेंगे? तो
देखो
स्प्ल में जब हमने लॉग इन किया है तो यहां
पे हमें लinक्स वाली पार्ट पे जाना है।
Windows तो हमें करना नहीं है इंस्टॉल। वन
2 में करना है वन टू इज अ लinक्स
आर्किटेक्चर तो यहां पर जाना है और यहां
पर आपको इसका जो डेब पैकेज है डेब क्योंकि
लinक्स में जो वन 2 में डेब पैकेज आपका
काम करता है एंड इसको आप इंस्टॉल कर सकते
हैं। सो यहां पे आपको डेब पैकेज को
डाउनलोड करना है। ठीक है? यू हैव टू
डाउनलोड द डेब पैकेज। दैट्स इट। व्हाट यू
विल डू? यहां पे आपको डब्ल्यू गेट का लिंक
मिलेगा। कॉपी लिंक आपको यहां पे आपको क्या
करना है? इसको कॉपी करनी है। यहां पे आपको
ये पूरा लिंक मिल जाएगा। ये वाला ये वाला
कॉपी करना है और इसको इधर आपको पेस्ट करना
है। अब देखो यहां पे दिक्कत क्या है? यहां
पे आप कंट्रोल शिफ्ट V प्रेस करोगे। ये
पेस्ट ही नहीं होगा। यहां पे ये टर्मिनल
के अंदर में जनरली काम नहीं करेगा। X1 का
सपोर्ट चाहिए होता है बेसिकली ग्राफिकल
थोड़ा ये सब चीज़ करने के लिए। तो ये करेगा
नहीं। तो अब इसको कैसे हम करेंगे भाई? हाउ
वी विल डू दैट? तो हमें यहां पे
एक काम करना पड़ेगा। व्हाट वी हैव टू डू?
हमें यहां पर इस मशीन इस उबू मशीन में
एसएसएच करना पड़ेगा एसएसएच करके और तब
हमें ये करनी पड़ेगी। अब एसएसएच कैसे
करेंगे? तो हम यहां पे IP एडर सर्च करेंगे
IP एड्रेस। तो हमें IPपी एड्रेस हमें इस
मशीन की दिखेगी। देखो होस्ट ओनली वाली
IPपी एड्रेस कौन सी है? यह वाली है। 19268
232.128 ये होस्ट ओनली वाली है। ठीक है?
यहां पे एक और है
19268.233.131
ये नेट वाली आईपी है। ठीक है? तो हमें
क्या करना है गाइज़? हमें इसमें एसएसएच
करना है। वी हैव टू एसएसएच इट। तब हम यहां
पे क्या कर सकते हैं? इंस्टॉलेशन मतलब
स्प्लंक की जो है इंस्टॉलेशन कर सकते हैं।
सिंपल। अभी मैं एलएस करूंगा। तो यहां पे
ऑलरेडी स्प्लक का एक डेव फाइल आपको देखने
को मिलेगा। मैं यहां पे आर एम करके यहां
पे स्प्लंक कर देता हूं। मैं इसको रिमूव
कर देता हूं। ठीक है? मैं यहां पे क्लियर
कर देता हूं। मैं एलएस करूंगा यहां पे। तो
यहां पे कोई सी भी फाइल नहीं है। नथिंग इज़
देयर। राइट? कुछ भी यहां पे आपको नहीं दिख
रहा है। ठीक है? अब हम यहां पे क्या
करेंगे? एसएसएच करेंगे।
एसएसएच करने के लिए हम Windows से ही इसको
कर सकते हैं। Windows से मैं टर्मिनल ओपन
करता हूं। एंड यहां पे मैं एसएसएच करूंगा।
किसको? उबू को करना है। तो उटू का यूजरनेम
क्या है? किस यूजरनेम के लिए हम कर रहे
हैं? तो डिफ़्रॉनिक्स यूजरनेम आई थिंक था @
एंड जो उसकी आईपी है तो 192. 168. 2328
आई थिंक यही था। हम एंटर करते हैं। लेट्स
सी यस करते हैं। पासवर्ड मांग रहा है। मैं
यहां पे पासवर्ड दे देता हूं। एंटर करता
हूं। एंड वी आर इंसाइड दैट सिस्टम नाउ। सो
अब हम यहां पे उस सिस्टम के अंदर में एलएस
करेंगे। कुछ भी नहीं मिलेगा। अब इसका मैं
आपको एग्जांपल देता हूं कि उस सिस्टम के
अंदर में हम कैसे हैं? हम यहां Windows का
यह Windows का हमारा टर्मिनल है। अब यहां
पे मैं एक डायरेक्टरी बनाता हूं एमके
डीआईआर एंड टेस्ट नाम से और मैं इस
वीएमवेयर के अंदर में इसमें जाऊंगा ना अभी
ये मैं वीएमवेयर के अंदर में हूं उबू में।
अब यहां पे मैं एलएस करूंगा तो वो टेस्ट
नाम की डायरेक्टरी आपको दिख जाएगी। यानी
कि वी आर इनसाइड दिस मशीन। तो अब हमें बस
Windows से ही वो कमांड W गेट वाली चलानी
है। तो वो तो ऑलरेडी हमने कॉपी किया था।
ये हमने यहां पे पेस्ट किया और अब हम यहां
पे एंटर कर देते हैं। अब ये डब्ल्यू गेट
कमांड जो है ये पूरी की पूरी जो स्प्लक
एंटरप्राइज है उसको डाउनलोड करेगी। आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे डाउनलोड जो है ऑलमोस्ट 1
मिनट का टाइम लगेगा। 6% 7% डाउनलोडिंग जो
है स्टार्ट हो रही है। तो डाउनलोड तो हम
Windows टर्मिनल पे कर रहे हैं। बट
क्योंकि हम उस untटू मशीन के अंदर में हैं
Windows टर्मिनल के थ्रू। तो हमारा
डाउनलोड जो होगा वो इस मशीन के अंदर में
यहां पे VMware के अंदर में U1 के अंदर वो
हो जाएगी। तो हमारे पास डेव फाइल आ जाएगी
जो इंस्टॉलेशन फाइल है एंड वहां से हम
इंस्टॉलेशन चालू कर सकते हैं क्योंकि
पेस्ट नहीं हो रहा था तो यह तरीका हमने
आजमा लिया है। ठीक है? चलिए
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
लेट इट कंप्लीट। मजा आ रहा है गाइस बता
दीजिए और लाइक ठोकते जाना भाई। जो भी आ
रहे हो जो भी आ रहे हो लाइक ठोक ही देना
क्योंकि बहुत मजेदार क्लास है आज की।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
सॉरी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके वेरी गुड जीयूआई में आपने करा है तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सर वेरी
थैंक्स फॉर द ग्रेटेस्ट कंटेंट आपके जैसा
कोई नहीं है साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंडस्ट्री
में गुड ऑलवेज ब्लेस यू थैंक यू वेरी मच
ब्रदर फॉर योर गुड वर्ड्स
राइट क्लिक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
पेस्ट नहीं होता उसमें।
वेरी गुड जगत गुरु स्वामी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
हाउ टू गेट नोट्स? नोट्स के लिए वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में एसओसी के जो भी क्लासेस
हैं डिस्क्रिप्शन में ग्रुप का लिंक होगा
आपके एसओसी का उसको ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा।
उसी ग्रुप में Google ड्राइव का लिंक
मिलता है जिसमें सारे नोट्स सारे
रिसोर्सेज आपके होते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? आई होप इट हेल्प्स। चलिए तो यहां
पे डाउनलोड ऑलमोस्ट फिनिश हो चुका है।
सॉरी [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ऑलमोस्ट डाउनलोड हैज़ बीन फिनिश्ड। 90% हो
चुका है।
10 सेकंड में ये 100% हो जाएगा।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
डन। तो ये डाउनलोड हो चुका है। यहां पे
सेव्ड हो चुका है। अब मैं इसको अभी फिलहाल
मिनिमाइज कर देता हूं। हम अपने वीएमवेयर
में चलते हैं। उबन टू पे चलते हैं अब यहां
पे और हम यहां पे एलएस करते हैं। यू विल
सी स्प्लंक का फाइल आ चुका है। अब हमें
इंस्टॉल करनी है। तो इंस्टॉल के लिए कमांड
है डीपीकेजी
डीपीकेजी डेबियन पैकेज इसको बोलते हैं।
hfन आई इंस्टॉल के लिए एंड स्प्लंक दैट्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इट। एंटर करेंगे
एंड जो है इंस्टॉल हो जाएगी। बट यहां पे
क्या कर रहा है कि प्रिविलेज चाहिए तो
यहां पे हमें सूडो लगाना पड़ेगा क्योंकि
हम नॉर्मल यूजर से लॉगिन है फिलहाल के
लिए। तो हमें यहां पे स्टार्टिंग में सूडो
कमांड का यूज़ करना पड़ेगा डीपीकेजी कमांड
को यूज़ करने के लिए। सो यू विल यूज़ सूडो
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
क्या हुआ भाई?
हां सूडो एंड एंटर करेंगे। अब ये पासवर्ड
मांगेगा। हमने यहां पे पासवर्ड दिया और
एंटर करेंगे। अब ये जो है इंस्टॉलेशन जो
है वो स्टार्ट हो जाएगी यहां पे। अब यहां
पे ऑलरेडी जो स्प्लंक है ये इंस्टॉल्ड है
अ इस सिस्टम के अंदर में। तो यहां पे आई
डोंट थिंक ये आगे इंस्टॉलेशन करेगा। बट
आपका जो है नॉर्मल इंस्टॉलेशन चलेगा। कुछ
देर इंस्टॉलेशन चलेगी और आपकी स्पंक जो है
वो इंस्टॉल हो जाएगी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
सो लेट इट कंप्लीट पहले।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इसको कंप्लीट होने देते हैं पहले।
सो यहां पे ऑलरेडी स्प्लक जो है मैं
मेरी जो स्प्लंक है ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड है।
इसमें पहले से आपको बस यह कमांड चलानी है।
आपकी इंस्टॉल्ड हो जाएगी। कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं आएगी। आप आराम से डीपीकेजी हफन आई
प्लंक चला दीजिएगा। एंड इट विल बी
इंस्टॉल्ड। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सो लेट इट फिनिश फर्स्ट। इसको मैं ज़ूम
मतलब फुल स्क्रीन में ला ला देता हूं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एसओसी का काम क्या होता है? मतलब एज अ
एसओसी एनालिस्ट आप काम क्या करेंगे? कोई
अटैकर होगा वो अटैक करेगा आपके नेटवर्क
सिस्टम पे और उस सिस्टम से आप लॉग
निकालेंगे और स्प्लंक डैशबोर्ड पे यानी कि
सिम डैशबोर्ड एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड पे आप उसको
रीड करेंगे एनालाइज करेंगे अलर्ट्स आएंगे
आपके सामने ये सब होगा हम वही चीज कर रहे
हैं हम अटैकर एक काली मशीन रख रहे हैं
विक्टिम मशीन जिसप अटैक होगा वो Windows
रख रहे हैं और उमटू के अंदर स्प्लंक हमने
सिम सेटअप किया है स्प्लक का सेट जो सिम
सॉफ्टवेयर सेटअप किया है वो करा हुआ है
ताकि हम उसे Windows से लॉग्स जो आए सिम
डैशबोर्ड में हम उसको एनालाइज है। दैट्स
इट। यही सेटअप करनी है पूरी और कुछ भी
नहीं करना है। तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
इसको हो जाने देते हैं। कितना टाइम लगेगा
भाई? जल्दी हो जा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
थोड़ा सा इसमें आपको टाइम देना पड़ेगा देन
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
इट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] विल बी डन
जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट सिंग अप
स्प्लक
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ये जो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एरर्स अभी
आ रहे हैं आपको सामने दिख रहे हैं इसको
इग्नोर कीजिएगा क्योंकि स्प्ल मेरा ऑलरेडी
इंस्टॉल था इसलिए ये एरर्स आ रहे हैं।
आपको स्टार्टिंग में कुछ भी एरर नहीं आएगा
जब आप पहली बार करेंगे। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब यह ऑलमोस्ट फिनिश होने वाला है। इट विल
बी फिनिशली।
अ दैट्स ग्रेट कपिल यू हैव फिनिश ऑल ग्रेट
टू हियर दैट ग्रेट दैट्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इट। यहां पे
स्प्लक इंस्टॉल हो चुका है। खत्म। यहां पे
इंस्टॉलेशन हो चुकी है स्प्लंक की। अब
यहां पे हमें क्या करना है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] स्प्लंक को
स्टार्ट करना है। ठीक है? वी हैव टू
स्टार्ट द स्प्लंक। अब यह स्प्लंक
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कैसे स्टार्ट
होगी? कैसे यह थोड़ा मैं आपको बताता हूं
किस तरीके से स्टार्ट होगी। पहली बार जब
स्प्लक आप स्टार्ट करेंगे। मैं मैं सोच
रहा हूं कि इस प्लंक को बिल्कुल ही
अनइंस्टॉल करके इंस्टॉल करके बताऊं मैं
आपको। तो डीपी केजी
एलएस करता हूं मैं यहां पे। है ना यहां पे
हम डीपी केजी
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
क्योंकि ऑलरेडी मेरे पास तो क्रिएट किया
हुआ है पासवर्ड तो डीपीकेजी अ यहां पे कर
देता हूं hfन पी एंड
प्लंक
अ
ओके यहां पर मैं एक काम करता हूं। सूडो
यूज़ कर लेते हैं। सूडो
अ डीपी के जी
एंड यहां पे हफन पी कर देते हैं। पूरी
तरीके से ये पर्ज कर देगा। मतलब पूरी
तरीके से ये हटा देगा उसको।
P एंड देन स्प्लंक।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
लेट्स सी यह रिमूव करेगा। आई थिंक
अ आई थिंक
इसको हम ठीक है।
एक बार आर भी लगा देते हैं
डीपीकेजी
और मैं यहां पे हफन आर रिकॉर्सिबली ये
हटाएगा
अ इग्नोरिंग रिक्वेस्ट टू रिमूव स्पंक
व्हिच इज़ नॉट इंस्टॉल्ड। चलिए नॉट
इंस्टॉल्ड आ गया। चलिए अच्छी बात है यहां
पे। अब सूडो अ
यहां पे एक बार जो लेफ्ट ओवर पैकेज है ना
उनको हटा देंगे तो ऐप ऑटो रिमूव कर देंगे
जो भी अनयूज्ड पैकेजेस है ये हट जाएंगे
ऑटो रिमूव से सो दैट्स इट सूडo ऐप अपडेट
कर देते हैं जब भी आप कोई इंस्टॉलेशन करते
हैं का लinक्स की ऐसे डिस्ट्रॉय तो आप
Sudo ऐप अपडेट जरूर कर दिया कीजिए इससे
बढ़िया हो जाती है। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तो ये ऐप टू
अपडेट एक बार चलने देते हैं। थोड़ा
रेपोज़िशन अपडेट हो जाता है। सब कुछ सही हो
जाता है। हो गया।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] दैट्स इट। अब
हम यहां पे स्प्लंक को इंस्टॉल
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] करेंगे फिर से।
मैं ऑलरेडी कर चुका था बट स्टार्टिंग से
करते हैं। डीपीकेजी हफन आई एंड स्प्लंक।
ठीक है? यहां पे अगेन सूडो डालना भूल गया
मैं। अदरवाइज़ ये परमिशन का इशू आ जाएगा।
सूडो लगा देते हैं यहां पे। सूडो
अ क्योंकि रूट का वो चाहिए। अनपैकिंग हो
रही है ये। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब
देखिए स्प्लंक अनपैकिंग हो रहा है एंड
इंस्टॉलेशन विल स्टार्ट। सो लेट इट
इंस्टॉल। पहले अब देखिए अब यहां पे ये
फ्रेश इंस्टॉलेशन हो रहा है। पहले की सारी
चीजें हटा दी है मैंने। ऑलमोस्ट सब चीजें
हट चुकी है यहां पे।
ठीक है?
तो नाउ सी। अब यहां पर वह जो पहले एरर आ
गई थी ना बहुत सारी कुछ कुछ एरर आ रही थी
वह एरर अब यहां पर आपको देखने को नहीं
मिलेगी। ठीक है? क्योंकि हम स्टार्ट फ्रेश
स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं तो आई डोंट थिंक इट
विल फच एनी काइंड ऑफ़ एरर। ठीक है? तो ये
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सेटिंग अप
स्प्लंक हो रहा है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ऑलरेडी डाउनलोड करने का आपको मैंने बता ही
दिया था कैसे डाउनलोड करना है। राइट? चलिए
सेटिंग अप हो रहा है। सेटिंग अप हो जाने
देते हैं। इनफ टाइम टू गेट अ जॉब या या या
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कुछ और एक चीज और मैं आपको बता देता हूं।
हमारे कुछ लर्नर्स को जो एसओसी के लर्नर्स
थे। पेड इंटर्नशिप मिली है एज एन स्टॉक
एनालिस्ट एसओसी के अंदर में। एंड आई रियली
कांग्रेचुलेट देम फॉर गेटिंग द इंटर्नशिप
एंड आई एम रियली रियली हैप्पी एंड प्राउड
कि उनको इंटर्नशिप मिल रही है वो भी पेड
इंटर्नशिप
ठीक है दो दो दो वीडियो दो या तीन वीडियो
और बची है बस उससे ज्यादा नहीं है दो या
तीन वीडियोस दैट्स इट उससे ज्यादा नहीं है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सेटिंग अप हो रहा है स्प्ल
आई एम आल्सो गोइंग टू मीट हर सर। किससे
मिलने जा रहे हो भाई?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
किससे मिलने जा रहे हो ये तो बताओ।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इट इज़ गेटिंग इंस्टॉल्ड
तो हमने अभी तक क्या किया? हमने VMware
में Kali इंस्टॉल किया। Windows 10
इंस्टॉल किया। Ubuntu इंस्टॉल किया। 1 जो
इंस्टॉल किया उसके ऊपर हमें स्प्लंक डालना
है। तो हमने उबू का वीएमवेयर का जो उबू है
उसका Windows टर्मिनल से लिया और वहां पे
डब्ल्यू गेट कमांड से स्प्लक एंटरप्राइज़
को डाउनलोड कर दिया। डेब जो डेबियन पैकेज
है जो आपको यहां पे डेब पैकेज दिख रहा
होगा डीईबी वाली और यहां पे आके हमने उसको
डीपीकेजी हफन आई इंस्टॉल ऑप्शन से हमने
इसको इंस्टॉल करना शुरू कर दिया और यह
इंस्टॉलेशन हो रही है सेटिंग अप दैट्स इट।
ठीक है? यहां पे एक आएगा फाइंड ये नो सच
फाइल डायरेक्टरी। इसको इग्नोर कर लीजिएगा।
डजंट मैटर उसके बाद आपकी इंस्टॉलेशन
कंप्लीट हो जाएगी।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट इंटर्नशिप ग्रेट।
या शोर पुरुषोत्तम
आई विल ट्राई माय बेस्ट।
गुड इवनिंग प्रशांत। गुड इवनिंग। गुड
इवनिंग ब्रदर।
नमस्ते। गुड इवनिंग सबको। चलिए इंस्टॉलेशन
हो चुकी है स्प्लंक की भैया हमारी। और
स्प्लंक का जो लोकेशन है वो मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं कहां पे वो होता है। ऑप्ट के
अंदर में आप जाएंगे ना ऑप्ट के अंदर में।
तो एलएस कर मैं तो स्प्लंक यहां पे आपको
देखने को मिलेगा। यह स्प्लंक है। ऑप्ट के
अंदर में एलएस करेंगे तो स्प्लंक की
फाइल्स यहां पे आपको देखने को मिल जाती
है। तो ऑप्ट के अंदर में स्प्लक देखने को
मिलेगा। अब इस प्लंक को हमें स्टार्ट करना
है। वी हैव टू स्टार्ट द स्प्लंक। अब इसको
हम कैसे स्टार्ट करेंगे भैया? स्प्लंक अ
बेसिकली हाउ वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग इट।
राइट? द मेन थिंग इज़ दैट। तो स्प्लंक को
यहां पे इंस्टॉल करने के लिए स्टार्ट करने
के लिए यहां पे कमांड आपको डालना पड़ेगा। द
कमांड इज़ सूडो।
उसके बाद बिन फाइल के अंदर कि स्प्लंक की
जो बाइनरी है उसको आपको एग्जीक्यूट करना
है। तो वह आपके ऑप्ट के अंदर में मिलेगा।
स्प्लंक डायरेक्टरी के अंदर में बन
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर में स्प्लक नाम से
मिलेगा। यह आपका पूरा का पूरा स्प्लंक का
पाथ होता है। अब यहां पे आप देखेंगे
स्टेटस इसका स्टेटस देखेंगे। तो यहां पे
आपको स्टेटस में यहां कुछ ये
टर्म्स एंड कंडीशंस आएगी। आप इसको स्पेस
देके नीचे आ जाइएगा। डू यू वांट टर्म्स
एंड कंडीशंस एक्सेप्ट करना है तो यस। यस
परफॉर्म माइग्रेशन एंड अपग्रेड विदाउट
प्रिवइंग कॉन्फ़िगरेशन चेंजेस यस कर देते
हैं यार।
अब यहां पे स्प्लंक जो है अ आ रहा है।
स्प्लंक इज़ नॉट रनिंग। मैंने स्टेटस देखा।
यहां पे आ रहा है स्प्लंक इज़ नॉट रनिंग।
ठीक है? ये हमने स्टेटस देखा। अब इसको
एग्जीक्यूट अगर करना है हमें तो सूडो यहां
पे
ये वाला चीज कर देंगे। यहां पे सिंपल यहां
पे सूडो ये वाला चीज कर देंगे और यहां पे
ऑप्शन स्टार्ट का देंगे। स्टार्ट करेंगे
एंटर करेंगे। अब यहां पे ये बोल रहा है कि
प्लंक को एज अ रूट जो है आप स्टार्ट ऐसे
नहीं कर सकते। इसमें आपको एक और पैरामीटर
देना पड़ेगा। वो क्या देना पड़ेगा कि रन
एज रूट एज रूट ये पैरामीटर देके स्टार्ट
करना पड़ेगा। अब आप एंटर करेंगे तो अब जो
है स्प्लंक स्टार्ट होना शुरू हो जाएगा।
एंड यहां पे अब लिखा आ रहा है वेटिंग फॉर
वेब सर्वर एट दिस टू बी अवेलेबल। मतलब अब
इस वेब सर्वर पे एक क्या होगी?
स्प्लंक की डैशबोर्ड जो है वो अवेलेबल हो
जाएगी। सो लेट्स सी देखते हैं यहां पे। अब
देखो यहां पे स्प्लक का वेब इंटरफ़ेस यहां
पे आपका मिल गया। डिफ़्रॉनिक्स स्प्लंक
कॉलन 8000 इस वेब इंटरफ़ेस को आप यहां से
एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। दिस इज़ द स्प्लक। अब
यहां पे गाइस यहां पे जब आप पहली बार
स्प्लंक को क्रिएट करेंगे। यहां पे जब आप
इसे इंस्टॉलेशन करेंगे फर्स्ट टाइम तो
आपसे यहां पे यूजरनेम और पासवर्ड क्रिएट
करने के लिए बोला जाएगा। तो आप यूजरनेम
पासवर्ड क्रिएट कर लीजिएगा। कुछ भी आप
क्रिएट कर सकते हैं। व्हाटएवर आपके माइंड
में जो भी यूजरनेम पासवर्ड है आप डाल
दीजिएगा। एट कैरेक्टर का होना चाहिए
पासवर्ड बस और कुछ नहीं है। कुछ भी आप डाल
सकते हैं। ठीक है? तो अब यहां पे ये
इंटरफ़ेस आ गया। अब ये इंटरफ़ेस डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
प्लंक कॉलन 8000 पोर्ट पे है। अब मैं क्या
करता हूं? इसको एक्सेस तो भाई किसी मशीन
में ही करेंगे ना। मतलब किसी वैसे मशीन
में। तो अब मैं यहां पे Windows पे ही
चलते हैं। लेट्स सपोज Windows पे एंड
देखते हैं ट्राई करके एक्सेस करके। सो हाउ
वी कैन एक्सेस इट? अब मैं यहां पर अगर
एक्सेस करूं डिफ्रॉनिक्स
प्लंक कॉलन 8000 इसको एक्सेस करके देखते
हैं। इफ इट इज़ ओपनिंग
इट्स नॉट ओपनिंग इफ इट इज़ ओपनिंग इट्स नॉट
ओपनिंग। ये देखो साइट कांट बी रीच्ड। चलो
ठीक है। एक और मुझे मेरे पास मिला था।
क्या था ये?
ये वाला 12701 कॉलन 8000 ये भी एक पाथ है।
तो इसको भी हम करके देख लेते हैं।
127.0.0.1
कॉलन 8000
इस पे जब हम गए तो यहां पे हमारा एक्सेस
हो चुका है। अब वो जो था ना वो एक डोमेन
था जो हम यहां से वो रिज़ॉल्व नहीं कर पा
रहे थे। एक्सेस नहीं कर पा रहे तो बट हमने
जैसे ही लोकल होस्ट पे किया यहां पे हमने
Windows से इसको एक्सेस कर लिया है। तो
हमने 12701 कॉलन 8000 पे ये स्प्लैंक एक्स
अब यूजरनेम तो मैं यूजरनेम यहां पे मैंने
बनाया था वो डाल देता हूं। पासवर्ड मैंने
शायद यही बनाया था याद नहीं आ रहा मुझे बट
ये मैंने डाल दिया और साइन इन कर दिया। जो
भी आपने क्रिएट किया जब पहली बार आप फ्रेश
इंस्टॉल करेंगे तो आप सिंपल सा यूजरनेम
पासवर्ड वहां पे आएगा कि यूजरनेम बताइए
पासवर्ड बताइए। आप बना दीजिएगा। दैट्स इट।
साइन इन कर दीजिएगा। अब यह क्या आ रहा है?
ओके। मुझे अब याद ही नहीं है। स्प्लंक
इसका यूजरनेम क्या था यार?
एडमिन नहीं था क्या?
यूजरनेम तो एडमिन था।
पासवर्ड कुछ और मैंने बनाया था शायद।
अ
पासवर्ड कुछ और बनाया था मैंने।
लेट्स सी। नहीं ये भी नहीं था।
तो
आई डोंट रिमेंबर
मैं [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एक बार
डायरेक्ट इस पे कर लेता हूं। इस पर चेक
करता हूं। शायद इस पर कुछ हो।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके आई एम नॉट गेटिंग द यूजरनेम हियर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अरे मैंने बनाया हुआ था बट
आई थिंक इसका कुछ इशू तो है।
मैं एक बार चेक कर लेता हूं।
लेट्स गो टू द स्प्लंक डायरेक्टरी। तो
यहां पे सीडी ऑप्ट में चलते हैं। एलएस
करते हैं। प्लंक पे चलते हैं। एलएस करते
हैं। अ सॉरी सीडी स्प्लक पे चलते हैं।
एलएस करते हैं। एंड यहां पे हमारे पास
सीडी ईटीसी में चलते हैं। एलएस करते हैं।
एंड लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज द पैकेजेस ईटीसी
के अंदर।
पास डब्ल्यूडी फाइल दिख रही है हां पास
डब्ल्यूडी फाइल है ना कैट
पास डब्ल्यूडी
अ यहां से परमिशन डिनाइड है ओके सूडो लगा
के होगा
हां [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये है एडमिन
ये पासवर्ड ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके सो
यूजरनेम तो एडमिन ही है यहां पे सो तो मैं
यहां पे
मैं यहां पे गाइस आई थिंक आई नीड टू
यहां पे मुझे यहां पे चेंज करना पड़ेगा
थोड़ा सा अ आई थिंक यहां पे आई नीड टू
यहां पे इसको हटाना पड़ेगा क्योंकि यहां
पे पास डब्ल्यूजी फाइल क्रिएट हो चुकी है
ना [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो यहां पे मुझे अह पास डब्ल्यूजी फाइल है
इसको थोड़ा सा वह कर देते
रिनेम करके शायद हो जाए ये।
आई थिंक
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
पार को हम अगर रिनेम कर देंगे तो आई थिंक
सही हो जाएगी ये।
चलो यहां पे मैं एक काम कर देता हूं। अ
लेट्स
मूव
पास डब्ल्यू डी टू पास डब्ल्यू डी डॉट
बीके आई थिंक ये हो जाएगा
मैं [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सूडो करके
देखता हूं
यस अब ये बीके हो गया pwd डॉट बीके हो गई
ये हां pwd बीके यहां पे ऑलमोस्ट हो चुका
है अब मैं यहां पे हम
ठीक है।
अ ईटीसी के अंदर ही हूं ना ईटीसी ईटीसी
कहां गया? ईटीसी ईटीसी एंड देन अभी सिस्टम
है कोई सिस्टम फोल्डर
देन इज़ सिस्टम यस सिस्टम इज़ देयर सीडी
सिस्टम में चलते हैं। एंड यहां एलएस करते
हैं। एलएस सिस्टम के अंदर में कौन सा है?
लोकल सीडी लोकल में चलते हैं। सॉरी सीडी
लोकल [खांसने की आवाज़]
एलएस करते हैं। एंड यहां पे कोई कौन सी
फाइल है? अ
लोकल के अंदर में
यूजर
शीट यूजर शीट यूजर शीट ऐसा तो कुछ है नहीं
यहां पे।
यहां पे मैं क्रिएट कर लेता हूं। अह एक
फ़ाइल क्रिएट कर लेते हैं। नैनो से ही कर
लेते हैं। नैनो अह यूज़र अह CF
एक यूजर C. हां, यह वाली बना लेते हैं।
लेट्स सी यहां पे डाल देते हैं यूजर info
यूजर अंडरs इनफो डाल देते हैं।
ओके
यूजरनेम मैं डाल देता हूं। ये एडमिन ही
रखते हैं। और [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इसका पासवर्ड जो है आई होप इट वर्क्स यहां
पे डाल देते हैं। अ पासवर्ड में मैं डाल
देता हूं। 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 वन से एट डाल
देते हैं। आई थिंक इतना हो जाना चाहिए। आई
थिंक मैं कंट्रोल एक्स कर देता हूं।
सेव करना है। यस यस
ओके परमिशन डिनाइड आ रहा है। परमिशन
डिनाइड क्यों आ रहा है भाई? अ
सूडो से नहीं बनाया था क्या?
ओके मैं कंट्रोल एक्स यहां पे करके नो कर
देता हूं।
सूडो नहीं नैनो सूडो सूडो नैनो कर देते
हैं। सूडो नैनो
यस इट। अब यहां पे कर देते हैं।
मैं यहां पे एक ट्राई कर रहा हूं बनाने
का। यूजर इनफो
डाल देता हूं। यहां पे यूजरनेम डालते हैं।
यूजरनेम इज इक्वल टू अ एडमिन
एंड यहां पे पासवर्ड। पासवर्ड = 128 डाल
देते हैं। कुछ भी डाल देते हैं। एडमिन
यूजर इनफो। ठीक है? आई होप कि अब सेव हो
जाए। यह यस सेव हो गया। ठीक है? एलएस करते
हैं। ये फाइल आ गई। यूजर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] co हो गया। अब
यहां पे सेम कमांड यूज़ करते हैं। यहां पे
सूडो रिस्टार्ट करते हैं इस प्लंक को। अ
कहां गया भैया?
सूडो स्प्लंक यहां पर रिस्ट
यहां री
सॉरी
रीस्टार्ट करते हैं। लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़
हैपनिंग। इट्स रिस्टार्टिंग देखते हैं
फिर। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अ सो लेट्स सी इफ इट इज़ वर्किंग। हाउ इट
इज़ वर्किंग और नॉट कैसे है?
अभी ये सर्वर डाउन हो चुका होगा। आई थिंक
रीलोड करते हैं।
स्टार्ट हो गई क्या ये सर्वर?
वेटिंग।
हां, डिफ़्रॉनिक्स प्लंक। ठीक है?
अब यहां पर एडमिन डालते हैं और यहां
पासवर्ड 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 डालते हैं। लेट्स
ट्राई टू लॉग इन। नहीं हो रहा है यहां पे।
लॉग इन फेल्ड।
राइट नाउ वी हैव चेंज्ड इट। सो एक काम कर
लेते हैं। इसको हटाते हैं।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
Windows 10 का मशीन ऑन करते हैं। चलिए
Windows 10 को स्टार्ट करते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एंड लेट्स सी। सो बूट करते हैं नॉर्मली जो
हमारा जो हमारी यह जो विंडज़ है ये मैं उस
Windows की बात कर रहा हूं जो हमारे उबन
VMware के अंदर में है जो हमारा विक्टिम
मशीन है हम उसको स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं। ठीक
है? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके ये हो गई। अब इसके ब्राउज़र ओपन कर
लेते हैं एक बार।
ठीक है।
यह [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हमने रीलोड
किया। अब यहां पर हम अब हम यहां पे
स्प्लंक का जो है एक बार स्टार्ट एक बार
देखते हैं। लाइक अ पहले तो स्टार्ट
जो आईपी है उस पे हम करते हैं। तो हम यहां
पे एक जो उबू की आईपी है हमारी जो स्प्लंक
वाली उसकी आईपी को देखते हैं। यहां पे
चलते हैं।
IP एडर [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो यहां पर यह आपकी जो होस्ट ओनली IP है
ना 192 168 232.128 हम इसको एक्सेस करेंगे
यहां से। ठीक है?
128 वाली है ना इसको। सो लेट्स गो टू द
Windows 10
तो 192.18000
इस पे हम चलते हैं। लेट्स सी एंड इस पे
हमारा स्प्लंक स्टार्ट हो जाएगा। ठीक है?
ठीक है। हम यहां पे डालते हैं एडमिन और
यहां पे हम पासवर्ड डालते हैं
जो हमने पासवर्ड क्रिएट किया था। साइन इन
करते हैं। लेट्स सी।
ओके ये हो गया।
सो फाइनली साइन इन यहां हो चुकी है गाइस।
अ
वी हैव साइन इन हियर फाइनली इन द स्प्लक।
मुझे नहीं पता इस पे क्यों नहीं हो रहा था
यह। व्हाई इट वाज़
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] नॉट ओपनिंग
हियर। सो मैं यहां पे एक बार आई थिंक यहां
भी हो जाएगी शायद। मैं यहां पे एक बार
करके देखता हूं। वहां की आईपी डालता हूं।
168.2328
यही थी ना आईपी। हां यही आईपी थी। कॉलन
8000 पोर्ट दे देते हैं। मेन ओएस पे मेन
उस पे डालते हैं। एंड यहां पे हम एडमिन
डालते हैं। एंड यहां पासवर्ड 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 उस टाइम हो सकता है रीस्टार्ट पूरी नहीं
हुई होगी शायद। हां, हो गई। यहां भी हो
गई। वेरी गुड। सो वी डोंट नीड ऑन दिस
मशीन। सो इसको फिलहाल के लिए मैं यहां से
लॉग आउट कर देता हूं। गुड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
फाइनली इट्स डन। ठीक है? तो हम यहां पे
स्प्लक डैशबोर्ड में आ चुके हैं। भैया वी
हैव इंसाइड दिस। ठीक है? एंड हमने पासवर्ड
चेंज किया। हमने स्प्लक का पासवर्ड मैंने
चेंज किया था गाइस। वो मैंने स्टेप आपको
ज्यादा डिटेल में नहीं बताया था क्योंकि
उसकी रिक्वायरमेंट थी नहीं आपको बेसिकली।
स्प्लंक का अगर आप एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का
पासवर्ड भूल जाते हैं कुछ ऐसे है तो सर्वर
साइड से स्प्लंक का बैक एंड से आप पासवर्ड
चेंज कर सकते हैं। सिंपल सा उसका बहुत
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सिंपल सा तरीका होता है कि स्प्रंग का एक
अ डायरेक्टरी है लाइक आप जो भी स्प्रिंग
का डायरेक्टरी वहां चले जाइए सीडी ऑप्ट के
अंदर में सॉरी सीडी ऑप्ट के अंदर में कहां
गया भाई
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां एलएस
करेंगे तो सीडी स्प्लक में चले जाइएगा आप
यहां एलएस करेंगे तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे एक फाइल
आपको डायरेक्टरी मिलेगी कौन सी डायरेक्टरी
है ईटीसी की तो ईटीसी में जाएंगे आप तो
यहां पर आपको ईटीसी के अंदर में एक फाइल
मिलेगी पासवर्ड पास डब्ल्यूडी फाइल यह pwd
फाइल इसको आप pwd डॉटbk कर दीजिएगा और
उसके बाद आपको यहां पे सिस्टम में जाना है
सीडी सिस्टम में एलएस करेंगे यहां पे उसके
बाद लोकल में जाना है cd लोकल
डायरेक्टरी यहां पे आप अह लोकल में जाइएगा
एंटर कर दीजिएगा और इसमें आपको एक क्रिएट
करनी है फाइल फाइल क्रिएट करनी है जो कि अ
उस पासवर्ड को बेसिकली रिसेट कर देता है।
सिंपली क्या करता है? उसको रिसेट कर देता
है। नथिंग इट। तो अब उस फाइल को जब आप
क्रिएट जब उस फाइल को क्रिएट करेंगे तो उस
फाइल के अंदर में कुछ एंट्री करनी होती
है। उस फाइल का नाम है यूजर सीड डॉट
कॉन्फ। यूजर सीड डॉट कॉन्फ। ये फाइल आप
क्रिएट करेंगे। कुछ इस तरीके से फाइल
क्रिएट करेंगे। यह फाइल का नाम होगा यूजर
सीड डॉट कॉन्फ। एंड इसके अंदर एक एंट्री
होती है। वह एंट्री ऐसे होगी यूजर इनफो
यूजर अंडरs इनफो देन यहां पर यूजरनेम
होगा। यूजर नेम इज़ इक्वल टू जो भी यूजरनेम
डालना है और पासवर्ड इज़ इक्वल टू जो भी
पासवर्ड आपको डालना है और सेव कर दीजिए।
दैट्स इट। आपकी जो फाइल और सिस्टम और जो
आपका
स्प्लंक है उसको रीस्टार्ट कर दीजिए।
रीस्टार्ट करने के लिए भी सेम वही जो
कमांड होती है। आपको वही यूज़ करना है
रीस्टार्ट करने के लिए। अह लाइक
सूडो
ओपीटी
स्प्लक
बिन स्प्लंक एंड रिस्ट बस वही फिर रन एज अ
रूट वाला जो करके वो कर देना है। दैट्स
इट। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बस इतना ही करना है। एंड योर सर्वर स्पंक
इज़ अह एक्चुअली स्टार्टेड।
आ चुका। अब हमारा सब कुछ यहां पे एवरीथिंग
इज़ रेडी नाउ हियर। नाउ वी हैव टू डू द
नेक्स्ट प्लॉट। अब आपको स्प्लंक आपका
इंस्टॉल हो चुका है उबू के ऊपर में। ठीक
है? अब उबू में आपको एक चीज करनी है। उबू
के अंदर चलना है और इसका फायरवल का स्टेटस
देखना है। फायरवल स्टेटस उबू में फायरवल
होता है। सूडो करेंगे यूएफW
यूएफW उसका स्टेटस देखना है। ठीक है? UFW
करेंगे। एंटर करेंगे। ये इनएक्टिव है। अगर
ये इनक्टिव है तो इसको बिल्कुल इनक्टिव
रहने देंगे। इसको एक्टिव नहीं करना है।
इनक्टिव नहीं है तो आप क्या करेंगे? सूडो
ufw एंड यहां पे इसको स्टॉप कर देंगे।
इसको मतलब डिसेबल कर देंगे। आप डिसेबल कर
देंगे। ये डिसेबल हो जाएगी। बस इसको बंद
कर देंगे। ठीक है? UFW आप करके एंटर
कीजिएगा। तो इसके कमांड्स भी आपको दिख
जाएंगे। तो आपको यहां पे दिखेगा कि इनेबल
करने के लिए इनेबल कमांड, डिसेबल करने के
लिए डिसेबल कमांड। तो इसको आप फायरवल को
बेसिकली आप डिसेबल कर देंगे। दैट्स इट। अब
यहां पे गाइस एक चीज आती है वो चीज क्या
है कि स्प्लंक का रिसीविंग रिसीवर जो है
वो सेटअप करना पड़ेगा। आपको एक रिसीवर
सेटअप करने का स्प्लंक के अंदर में अब ये
रिसीवर कैसे सेटअप करना है मैं आपको बता
देता हूं। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देखो
स्प्लंक एक पोर्ट पे रिसीव करता है। जो भी
डेटा उसके पास आएगी लॉग्स आएंगी वो एक
पोर्ट पे रिसीव करेगा। वो पोर्ट जो है वो
रिसीव आपको पोर्ट जो है कॉन्फ़िगर करनी
पड़ेगी आपके स्प्लंक डैशबोर्ड में। ये आपका
काम है। ये आपको करना ही करना पड़ेगा। अब
ये आप कैसे करेंगे ये मैं आपको बता देता
हूं। देखो इसका कमांड लाइन भी है। आपका
ग्राफिकल भी है। सब कुछ है। बट मैं आपको
यहां पे ग्राफिकल और थोड़ा इजी तरीके से
बता देता हूं ताकि आपका लाइक अ ईज़ली आपका
वो कर पाएंगे। तो आप सिंपली यहां पे
स्प्लंक का जो डैशबोर्ड है इसके ऊपर
जाएंगे। यहां पर आप लॉग इन आपने कर लिया
है। यहां पर आप सेटिंग में जाएंगे। सेटिंग
में आपको यहां पे एक ऑप्शन मिलेगा
फॉरवर्डिंग एंड रिसीविंग। आपको इस पे जाना
है। जब आप इस पे जाएंगे फॉरवर्डिंग एंड
रिसीविंग पे
तो यहां पे आपको मिलेगी कॉन्फ़िगर
रिसीविंग। कॉन्फ़िगर रिसीविंग का ऑप्शन
मिलेगा। इस पे आप क्लिक कर दीजिएगा।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
तो, यहां पे आपको ऐड करना है न्यू
रिसीविंग पोर्ट। यहां पे ऑलरेडी मेरा यह
ऐडेड है। मैं इसको अभी फिलहाल डिलीट कर
देता हूं। यहां पे न्यू रिसीविंग पोर्ट पे
ऐड करना है।
यहां पे लिसन ऑन दिस पोर्ट। आपको एक पोर्ट
नंबर असाइन करना है। अब यहां पे पोर्ट
नंबर जो डिफ़ॉल्ट पोर्ट नंबर जिस पे आपको
लिसन करवाना है, ये लिसन आप 597 पे आप कर
सकते हैं जो डिफ़ॉल्ट एक पोर्ट नंबर है।
सेव कर देना है। सेव करेंगे। अब यहां पे
ये लिसनिंग स्टार्ट हो जाएगी। इनेबल्ड हो
जाएगा ये। एंड दैट्स इट। आपको बस ये करना
है। तो यहां पे अब क्या हो रहा है कि
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे लिसनिंग स्टार्ट हो जाए। अब इसको
वेरीफाई आपको करना है कि ये एक्चुअली
पोर्ट लिसन कर भी रहा है कि नहीं कर रहा
है। तो ये आप उबंटू से वेरीफाई
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कर सकते हैं। उबंटू में आप जाएंगे यहां पे
एक कमांड होती है सूडो
एसएस ये कमांड आपकी होती है एलएन टीपी हफन
एलएन टीपी इस कमांड का यूज़ करेंगे और
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे ग्रैब
करेंगे कि 597 वाली जो पोर्ट है इस पे कुछ
लिसन हो रहा है कि नहीं। यहां पे कुछ भी
अगर नहीं आता है आउटपुट तो लिसन नहीं हो
रहा है। कुछ आउटपुट आ रहा है तो मतलब लिसन
हो रहा है। ठीक है? एंटर करते हैं। अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे आप
देखेंगे कि यहां पे हमें एक आउटपुट मिली
है लिसन और यहां पे क्या हो रहा है?
यूजर्स प्लंक डी एंड यहां पे लिसनिंग चालू
है। यानी कि हमारा लिसनिंग जो है वो
प्रॉपर्ली कॉन्फ़िगर हो चुका है। नाउ
एवरीथिंग इज़ सेट अप। अब यहां पे हमें इस
लिसनिंग वाला पार्ट का कुछ नहीं करना।
इट्स टोटली फाइन। मतलब यह एकदम बिल्कुल
सही से काम कर रहा है। आपने एक लिसनिंग
पोर्ट जो है वो सेटअप सॉरी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वो सेटअप कर दी
है। दैट्स इट। अब इसके बाद आपको क्या करना
है? एक और चीज करनी है। आपको करना है
Windows का एक इंडेक्स बनाना है इस प्लंक
के अंदर में। कैसे बनाना है? फिर से अगेन
इस प्लंक पे जाइए यहां पे। अब यहां पे
आपको फिर से सेटिंग्स में जाने हैं। और
यहां पे एक ऑप्शन मिलेगा आपको इंडेक्सेस
का।
इंडेक्सेस इस इस इंडेक्सेस ऑप्शन पे जाइए
यहां पे। और यहां पे Windows के लिए एक
इंडेक्स आपको बनानी है। तो यहां पे मैंने
ऑलरेडी आई थिंक इंडेक्स बनाई होगी। मैं
यहां पे पेज टू पे जाता हूं। देखता हूं।
Windows इंडेक्स यहां पे बनी हुई है यहां
पे ऑलरेडी।
सॉरी [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
मैं इसको डिलीट कर देता हूं। यहां पे एक
इंडेक्स आपको बनानी है। मैं यहां पे फ्रेश
बनाता हूं।
यहां पर न्यू इंडेक्स करनी है। यहां पे
नाम देना है Windows। दैट्स इट। बाकी सब
चीजें ऐसे ही छोड़ देनी है आपको। कुछ नहीं
करना है। सेव पे क्लिक करना है। एंड यहां
पे आपका Windows नाम का एक जो है अ
आपका इंडेक्स जो है वो बनके तैयार हो
जाएगा। ठीक है? अब अगेन आप इस प्लग
इंटरप्राइजेस पे जाइए। यहां पे सेटिंग्स
पे जाइए। अगेन यहां पे आपको इंडेक्सेस पे
जाना है। इंडेक्सेस पे जाना है। एंड यहां
पे आपको चेक करना है आपकी जो इंडेक्स है
वो Windows वाली बनी है कि नहीं बनी है।
ये Windows वाली इंडेक्स है यहां पे। ये
आपकी एक्टिव है। ये आपकी बन चुकी है। यहां
पे फिलहाल के लिए मैं आप चाहे तो इसको जो
भी है डिसेबल इनेबल भी कर सकते हैं। जो भी
आपको करना है। व्हाटएवर यू वांट टू डू यू
कैन डू इट। ठीक है? तो यहां
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पे Windows नाम
की एक इंडेक्स आपको ऐसे बना देनी है। ये
आपका इसके बाद अब यहां पे आपका काम आ रहा
है Windows वाला जो हमें Windows पे करना
है। ये काम सारे काम आपने सेटअप कर लिया
है। अ
सर एवरीवन एक्सिस्ट इन द नेम ऑफ़
प्रैक्टिकल बट आफ्टर सम टाइम एवरीवन रंस
अवे। हां। जिनको इंटरेस्ट है वो रहेंगे।
कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है। इतना टेंशन आपको
नहीं लेना। इतना टेंशन नहीं लेना हमें।
इतना मस्त जो एक्चुअली में सीखना चाहते
हैं वो लास्ट लास्ट तक भी रहते हैं तो
उतनी कोई बड़ी बात नहीं। ठीक है? अब देखिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब इन सबके बाद वीएमवेयर के अंदर में जो
आपने Windows मशीन डाली है इसके अंदर में
एक सॉफ्टवेयर डालनी है एंड वो सॉफ्टवेयर
है Splunk का यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर। ये आपको
यहां पे डालनी है। तो Splunk का यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्डर कहां से इंस्टॉल करेंगे? तो आप
Google पे जाएंगे Splunk यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्डर। इसी Windows के अंदर में जो
आपकी VMware के अंदर में इंस्टॉल है। इसको
आप डाउनलोड कर लेंगे।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डाउनलोड यूनिवर्सल फॉर ऑर्डर का ऑप्शन आ
गया।
अगेन यहां पे लॉग इन करके आप डाउनलोड कर
सकते हैं। यहां पे आप लाइक यू हैव टू लॉग
इन हियर। यहां पे जाएंगे आप लॉग इन पे
क्लिक करेंगे।
तो जो आपने लॉग इन बनाया है स्प्लंक का
उससे लॉग इन कर लीजिए यहां पे। सो आई एम
जस्ट गोइंग टू लॉग इन।
चलिए यहां पर नेक्स्ट पर करते हैं।
यहां पर पासवर्ड डाल देते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
लॉग इन कर लेते हैं।
यह स्प्लक यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर क्या करता
है? जो भी Windows के
लॉग्स होंगे जो भी Windows के लॉग्स होंगे
उनको कलेक्ट करता है और उनको फॉरवर्ड करता
है स्प्लंक डैशबोर्ड को। तो यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्डर जो होते हैं स्प्लन के ये एंड
पॉइंट्स पे इंस्टॉल्ड होते हैं। जिस मशीन
से लॉग्स आपको सेम डैशबोर्ड में फॉरवर्ड
करनी है। तो Windows के ऊपर कोई भी अटैक
हो रहा है तो उसके लॉग्स को ये कलेक्ट
करता है और सेम डैशबोर्ड में भेजता है।
जहां पे आप बाकी लॉग्स को एनालाइज़ कर सकते
हैं। ये सारी चीजें इसमें होती हैं। चलिए
बढ़िया है। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सो वी
हैव द फॉर ऑर्डर। तो आपको Windows के लिए
ही चाहिए। तो सिंपल Windows 10 या Windows
10 11 जो भी आपको चाहिए वो आप यहां पे
यहां हमारा Windows 64 बिट है तो 64 बिट
वाला यह डाउनलोड नाउ पे क्लिक कर दीजिएगा
डाउनलोड हो जाएगी ऑलरेडी एंड आई थिंक इट्स
ऑलरेडी डाउनलोडेड हियर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
या स्प्लक फॉरवर्ड इसको डबल क्लिक कीजिएगा
इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा दैट्स इट इंस्टॉलेशन
प्रोसेस आपकी कंप्लीट हो जाएगी एंड हो गया
डबल क्लिक ऐसे करेंगे यहां पे ये ऑलरेडी
इंस्टॉल्ड है तो ये आ रहा है इसको इंस्टॉल
करने की जरूरत नहीं है यहां पे फिनिश कर
दीजिए ऐसे सिंपल एज दैट। अब इसकी
इंस्टॉलेशन प्रोसेस का भी मैं तरीका वो भी
बता देता हूं।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो मैं यहां
पे कंट्रोल पैनल पे चलता हूं। इसको
अनइंस्टॉल पहले करता हूं। फिर से इंस्टॉल
करके बताऊंगा क्योंकि इसमें कुछ चीजें
हैं। यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर है यहां पे।
अन इंस्टॉल कर देते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है?
इट्स अनइंस्टॉल्ड। यस।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए ये अनइंस्टॉल हो चुका है आपका
यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर। इसको वापस से
अनइंस्टॉल करके बताऊंगा क्योंकि इसमें कुछ
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चीजें हैं जो आपको देखनी है। ध्यान देनी
है। मतलब [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ये हो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
गया यहां पे
इंस्टॉल हो अनइस्टॉल हो गई। अब यहां पे
हमें इसको इंस्टॉल करना है। जहां पे हमने
डाउनलोड किया था। यहां चलते हैं।
डाउनलोड्स पे चलते हैं। यहां पे इस प्लंक
फॉरवर्ड को इंस्टॉल करना
शुरू कर देते हैं। यहां पे एक्सेप्ट
एग्रीमेंट यहां पे स्प्लंक एंटरप्राइज के
लिए सेलेक्ट करना है। यहां पे नेक्स्ट पे
क्लिक करना है। अब यहां पे यूजरनेम और
यहां पे पासवर्ड आपसे मांगेगा। यूजरनेम
पासवर्ड क्रिएट करना है आपको। तो आप लाइक
क्रिएट क्रेडेंशियल फॉर तो आप कुछ भी
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड क्रिएट कर दीजिए। तो मैं
यहां पे ऐडमिन और पासवर्ड में यहां पे
अगेन वही पासवर्ड डाल देता हूं। 1 2 8
वाली ताकि याद रहेगा। 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 यहां पे नेक्स्ट पर क्लिक
करते हैं। हो गया। अब यहां पे आ रहा है
डेप्लॉयमेंट सर्वर का यूजरनेम मतलब सॉरी
आईपी और यहां पे पोर्ट ये डिप्लॉयमेंट
सर्वर का आपसे पूछा जा रहा है। तो यहां पे
हमें कोई डेप्लॉयमेंट सर्वर हमने
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं किया है इस प्लंक का
फिलहाल के लिए। कोई हम ऐसा कुछ यूज़ भी
नहीं करने वाले डिप्लॉय भी नहीं करने
वाले। तो हमें यहां पे कुछ नहीं करना है।
नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक करना है। अब यहां है
रिसीविंग इंडेक्सर। अब रिसीविंग इंडेक्सर
वही है जो आपने इंडेक्सर बनाया है।
Windows का तो वो रिसीविंग इंडेक्सर का
यहां पे सेटअप आपको करना है। वो आपको यहां
पे देनी है आईपी एंड यहां पे पोर्ट नंबर।
तो भैया यहां पे आईपी क्या डालनी है? आईपी
आपको डालनी है किसकी आईपी डालनी है यहां
पे बताइए। ये आईपी आपकी डालनी है उबंटू
वाली। जो वन 2 वाली IP है वह आपको यहां पर
देनी है। तो 1 2 की IP जो क्या है जिस पे
स्प्लंक रन हो रहा है तो हम दे देते हैं
IP हेडर एंड [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
दिस इज़ 192 168 232.128
ये है। हम यहां पे डाल देते हैं
192.168.232.128
और पोर्ट नंबर जो हमने 597 किया था वही
पोर्ट नंबर हमने डाल दिया है। ठीक है? तो
हमने ये सेटअप कर दिया यहां पे अह
मतलब
ये जो हमारा उबू की आईपी थी हमने सेटअप कर
दिया। हम यहां पे नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक कर
देते हैं। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इंस्टॉल पे क्लिक कर देते हैं।
यूएसई का प्र्ट आएगा। यस कर दीजिएगा।
दैट्स इट। इंस्टॉलेशन जो है वो स्टार्ट हो
गई है। तो इट विल गेट इंस्टॉल्ड। जस्ट तब
तक के लिए वेट करते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एक फाइल की रिक्वायरमेंट इसमें पड़ेगी। वो
मैं फाइल जो है वो ले लेता हूं फिलहाल के
लिए। लेट मी गेट दिस द फाइल्स फर्स्ट
बिकॉज़ वो फाइल्स के बिना यहां पे थोड़ा सा
हो जाएगा।
हम ये हो चुकी है यहां पे। मैं यहां पे
फिनिश कर देता हूं। दैट्स इट। यह इंस्टॉल
हो चुका हमारा फॉर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
दैट्स इट। डन इट। अब यहां पे हमें इसकी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन करनी है। यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर
को हमें कॉन्फ़िगर करना है। कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के
लिए वी नीड अ फाइल। अ सो लेट मी अह
गेट द फाइल। मुझे एक फाइल आपको सिर्फ बता
दूंगा मैं कि इसमें एक्सजेक्टली क्या करना
है। बट वह फाइल पहले मैं ले लेता हूं।
ओके लेट मी टेक द फाइल हियर
चलिए मैं डायरेक्ट ऐसे ही बता देता हूं।
इसमें डायरेक्ट आपको बता देता हूं। आई
थिंक वो फाइल शायद एग्ज़िस्ट करती हो मे
बी। मैं एक बार देख लेता हूं वो फाइल
एग्जैक्टली एक्सिस्ट करती है फिलहाल कि
नहीं। एक लोकेशन है यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर
का। उस पे जाना है आपको। ठीक है? आई थिंक
वो फाइल मेरे पास ऑलरेडी है शायद। इनपुट
आउटपुट फाइल है ना ये? हां। ऑलरेडी फाइल
है। गुड। बहुत बढ़िया। तो आपको दो फाइल्स
आपको क्रिएट करनी है। क्या करनी है? मैं
आपको बताता हूं। आपको सिंपल सी में जाना
है। प्रोग्राम फाइल्स में जानी है।
यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर जो है उस पे जाना है।
कंटिन्यू यहां पे आपको करनी है। इसके अंदर
में आपको एक फोल्डर मिलेगी ईटीसी की। ठीक
है? सभी लोग यहां पे ध्यान दीजिएगा।
स्क्रीन पे ध्यान दीजिएगा। यहां पे एक
फोल्डर मिलेगी ईटीसी की। इसके अंदर में
आपको जाना है। ईटीसी के अंदर में आपको
मिलेगा सिस्टम। सिस्टम के अंदर में आपको
जाना है। सिस्टम के अंदर आपको जाना है
लोकल के अंदर में। लोकल के अंदर आप जाएंगे
तो यहां पे आपको यह चार फाइल्स देखने को
मिल रही है। दीज़ फोर फाइल्स आर हियर दैट
यू कैन सी। यहां पे मैं दो फाइल्स आपको
बनानी है। एक आउटपुट्स डॉट और एक inputs
डॉट कॉफ। ये दो चीज़ आपको यहां पे बनानी
है। दो फाइल्स यहां पे आपको क्रिएट करनी
है। अब इसमें क्रिएट क्या करना है? मैंने
यहां पे एक जगह पे लिख के रखा है। वो मैं
आपको अच्छे से थोड़ा बताता हूं। पहले मैं
दिस पीसी पे जाता हूं यहां पे। अ क्विक
एक्सेस पे चलते हैं। यहां पे आई थिंक इट
विल ओपन इनपुट्स एंड आउटपुट्स। देखते हैं।
आई थिंक नहीं है। ये है ही नहीं फाइल
एक्सिस्ट नहीं करता है। तो अब यहां पे सी
में प्रोग्राम फाइल्स में चलते हैं। प्लंक
फॉर ऑर्डर पे चलते हैं। यहां पे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ईटीसी के अंदर
चलते हैं। ईटीसी के अंदर में सिस्टम के
अंदर चलते हैं। सिस्टम के अंदर में लोकल
के अंदर चलते हैं। लोकल के अंदर में ये
फाइल्स दो फाइल्स यहां पे आपको दिख रही।
आउटपुट्स का एक फ़ाइल दिख रहा होगा आपको।
इसको जब आप ओपन करेंगे आउटपुट्स वाले फ़ाइल
को
कुछ इस तरीके की आपको यहां पे आउटपुट का
ये फाइल जो है वो दिखेगा।
एंड एक आपको इनपुट का फाइल यहां पर देख
करके बनानी है। तो आउटपुट वाली जो यह फाइल
है इसमें हम चेंज कर देते हैं। आउटपुट्स
डॉट ये डॉट कॉफ फाइल बनानी है। ये ऑलरेडी
कॉन्व फाइल है। देखिए आप ये आउटपुट जो है
ये देखेंगे कॉफ फाइल ऑलरेडी है। तो हमें
इसको एडिट करना है। एंड इसमें हमें कुछ
चेंजेस करने हैं। चेंजज़ क्या करने हैं?
मैं आपको बताता हूं। यहां पे है TCP आउट।
ठीक है? यहां पे मैंने एक कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
फाइल रखी है। वो चीज़ मैं आपको डायरेक्ट
बता रहा हूं। वही चीज़ आपको करनी है।
डिफ़ॉल्ट ग्रुप यहां पे आपको देना है।
डिफ़ॉल्ट ग्रुप में स्प्लक इंडेक्सर्स
ग्रुप आएगा। ये तो ये आएगा स्प्लक
स्प्लंक एंड यहां पे आ जाएगा इंडेक्स।
ये आपको यहां पे डालना है जो स्प्लंक
इंडेक्सेस है। सभी को समझ में आ रहा है
ना?
सभी को समझ में आ रहा है?
यहां पर मैं एक फाइल मतलब एक फाइल मैंने
रखा हुआ है सामने एंड उस फाइल की एंट्री
मैं यहां पे आपको बता रहा हूं। ये फाइल
बेसिकली मैं चाहूं तो मैं यहां पे आपको
डायरेक्ट लिख भी देता हूं। मैं यहां पे
मंगा भी लेता हूं एक फाइल के अंदर में।
जस्ट अ जस्ट अ सेकंड। मैं एक फाइल यहां पे
आपके लिए मैंने तैयार करके रखा हुआ है।
मैं यह मंगा लेता हूं। ठीक है? कौन सी
फाइल है वो सारी
रुक जाइए। एज अ फाइल आई एम जस्ट गेटिंग इट
लेट मी
यहां पर यह फाइल जो है
हां
अब ये मैं फाइल यहां पे इसमें इंसर्ट करते
हैं। एंड लेट्स सी इफ इट इज़ कमिंग ऑ नॉट
हियर।
तो मैं यहां पे किस में डालता हूं? ये कौन
सी है? Windows 10 है ना? Windows 10 पे
डालते हैं।
Windows 10 पे इसको इंसर्ट करते हैं। आई
होप कि इसमें आ जाए ये डिटेक्ट हो जाए।
अच्छी बात है। डिटेक्ट हो गई है।
ओपन फोल्डर
ये रहा पीडीएफ। ये फाइल मैंने क्रिएट करी
है। ये फाइल में यहां पे इनपुट्स। यहां पे
ये चीज़ इसी को हमें एंटर करना है। यही
चीजें हमें एंटर करनी है। तो आउटपुट्स डॉट
कॉन्फ में हमें डालना है स्प्लंक
इंडेक्सेस। यह आपकी होंगी और TCP
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आउट में यहां पे स्प्लक इंडेक्स इंडेक्स
ही डालने हैं यहां पे टीसीp आउट में। सो
वी विल बी
डूइंग TCP आउट में स्प्लक
इंडेक्स ये एंट्री करनी है आपको इंडेक्सेस
इस तरीके से आपको इंडेक्सेस की एंट्री
करनी है। और यहां पे सर्वर में आपको वो
सर्वर डालना है जो आपने बनाई थी। तो ये
हमने वही डलाई बनाई है 192 168.232.128
सर्वर एड्रेस बिल्कुल सही है और टीसीp आउट
सर्वर ये जो लास्ट लाइन है इसकी कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट यहां पे हमें फिलहाल के लिए
नहीं है। तो इसको हमने यहां पे हटा दिया।
ओके और हम इसको अब सेव कर देते हैं। सेव
किया हमने आउटपुट्स डॉट कॉन्फ जो है वो
हमारी
तैयार हो गई है जो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हमें चाहिए था।
अब हमें यहां पर एक फोल्ड एक यह तो हमें
अब हमें आउटपुट डॉट कॉफ अब हमें एक नई
फाइल बनानी है न्यू अ टेक्स्ट डॉक्यूमेंट
एंड यहां पे देना है इनपुट्स डॉट कॉफ
इनपुट्स
ठीक है एंड डॉट कॉफ ये आपकी एक फाइल बनेगी
इसको आपको बनाना है अब यहां पे हमने मान
लो इसको हम इनपुट्स करके रख देते हैं बाद
में इसको हम रिनेम कर देंगे इनपुट्स डॉट
को हम यहां पे ओपन करेंगे और यहां पे
हमारे पास जो इनपुट वाली फाइल है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एंट्री है वो
डालना है। वो एंट्री क्या डालनी है यहां
पे? देखिए ये जो आपकी एंट्री है
ये आपकी एंट्री यहां पे
डाल ली है। ठीक है? आई होप कि इट गेट्स
कॉपीड एंड पेस्टेड हियर।
ये एंट्री डालनी है। ये क्या है? मैं आपको
यह भी बताता हूं।
यहां पे एक-एक स्पेस दे दीजिएगा। जीरो।
देखिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इसका मतलब है कि ये जो लॉग्स ये कहां-कहां
से लॉग्स लेगा? कहां-कहां से ये लॉग्स जो
है ये उठाएगा। इसका मतलब यही है कि फ्रॉम
वेयर इट विल कलेक्ट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] द लॉग्स। तो ये
सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स को उठाएगा। जो Windows
के सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स हैं ये सिस्टम के
लॉग्स को उठाएगा। एप्लीकेशन के लॉग्स को
उठाएगा। ठीक है? यहां पे तो डिसेबल्ड है
नहीं ज़ीरो बंद मतलब वो है। इंडेक्स कौन सा
है? Windows जो हमने क्रिएट किया था वही
है। Windows जो हमने ये क्रिएट किया था
वही है। एंड यहां पे Windows जो हमने
क्रिएट किया था वही है। और एक और कौन सा
उठाएगा ये? Microsoft
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] Power शेल के भी
यहां पे अह
हां Microsoft [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
Power शेल के भी लॉक्स उठाएगा। ये इनपुट्स
का मतलब यही है। इसका मतलब देखो मैं आपको
अभी सब कुछ समझा दूंगा। यहां पे इक्वल टू
ज़ीरो कर देते हैं। इसको भी सेव कर देते
हैं और इसको क्लोज़ कर देते हैं। अब ये जो
फाइल हमने क्रिएट करी है गाइज़ ये इनपुट्स
नॉर्मल टेक्स्ट डॉक्यूमेंट है। बट हमें एक
कॉन फाइल चाहिए। तो डबल क्लिक इसको आप
करेंगे। इसको सिंपल सा आप यहां पे डबल
क्लिक करके फाइल करेंगे सेव एज करेंगे तो
यहां पे आपको इनपुट्स यहां ऑल फाइल करना
है इनपुट्स डॉट कॉफ लिखना है डॉट कॉफ और
इसको सेव कर देना है तो ये एक कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
फाइल की तरह भी आपकी यहां पे आ जाएगी
टेक्स्ट वाली फाइल को डिलीट कर दीजिएगा
इसकी कोई रिक्वायरमेंट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
नहीं है। तो यहां पे हमने दो फाइल बनाई है
इनपुट एंड आउटपुट ये फॉरवर्डर का काम क्या
है इनपुट वाली के अकॉर्डिंग ये लॉग्स की
इनपुट लेगा
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? और ये आउटपुट के अकॉर्डिंग जो है
ये एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड को आउटपुट देगा। तो
इनपुट के अकॉर्डिंग हम इनपुट को सॉरी
इनपुट के अकॉर्डिंग ये इनपुट लेगा। जो भी
लॉग्स के इनपुट है तो सिक्योरिटी के
लॉग्स, सिस्टम के लॉग्स, एप्लीकेशन के
लॉग, Microsoft पावर सेल के लॉग्स ये सब
कुछ इनपुट वगैरह लेगा। ठीक है? और आउटपुट
के अकॉर्डिंग ये कहां भेजेगा? लॉग्स को
स्प्लंक इंडेक्स को भेजेगा। किस एड्रेस पे
भेजेगा? इस IPपी एड्रेस पे इस पोर्ट पे
भेजेगा। और इसी पे हमारे इंडेक्स क्रिएट
किए थे हमने Windows वाले जहां पे सेम का
डैशबोर्ड जो है वो आपका यहां पे बड़ी
बेसब्री से इंतजार कर रहा है कि भैया यहां
पे कुछ [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तो होगा।
ठीक है? ये समझ में आ गया?
यहां तक क्लियर हुआ आप लोगों का? पहले
मुझे बताइए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
क्लियर है पहले बताइए मुझे
ऑल क्लियर
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है तो ये दो फाइल क्रिएट हो गई अब
हमारे पास ये कॉन्फ़िगरेशन जो है वो हो
चुका है कॉन्फ़िगरेशन इसमें इसमें आप और भी
कहीं-कहीं से लॉग्स कलेक्ट करना चाहते हैं
ना जैसे ये जो मैंने इनपुट का बनाया फाइल
इसमें और भी कहीं-कहीं से सिक्योरिटी
सिस्टम इनके अलावा कहीं भी से भी लॉग्स
क्रिएट करना है तो आप यहां पे ये एंट्री
करके आप कर सकते हैं।
कोई बात नहीं एक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बार रिवाइज कर लीजिएगा, रिपीट कर लीजिएगा।
क्लियर? अब जब ये लॉग्स ये जो कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
हमने चेंजेस करे हैं। इसके बाद यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्ड जो हमारी स्प्लक यूनिवर्सल फॉर
ऑर्डर है, इसको हमें रिस्टार्ट करनी
पड़ेगी। तो इसके लिए हमें पावर शेल लेना
है। पावर शेल ओपन कर देनी है। सॉरी पावर
शेल को हमें एज एन एडमिन ओपन करना है।
इसको आप यूज़ जब करेंगे तो पावर शेल को एज
एन एडमिन ऐप एज एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर करेंगे। यस
करेंगे। यह स्टार्ट पावर शेल स्टार्ट हो
गया। अब यहां पे करेंगे क्या? रिस्ट
सॉरी यह क्या आ गया भाई?
री स्टार्ट
सर्विस एंड यहां पे आपको देना है स्प्लंक
अ फॉरवर्ड रिस्ट सर्विंग सर्विस स्प्लंक
फॉरवर्ड ये आपको करना है तो हमने ये कर
दिया अब यहां पे हम क्या करेंगे
एंटर करेंगे हमने एंटर किया सर्वर जो
स्प्लक फॉरवर्ड है वह स्टार्ट हो जाएगी
रिस्टार्ट हो जाएगी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हो गया। ये स्टार्ट हो गया। अब इसको एक
बार चेक कर लेंगे। तो गेट
अरे यार
गेट सर्विस
गेट सर्विस एंड स्प्लक सॉरी स्प्लंक फॉर
ऑर्डर ये देखेंगे तो यह रनिंग है। अब यह
काम कर रही है। ठीक है? अब यहां पे आई
थिंक कुछ इशू हुआ है। जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस।
एक सेकंड रुक जाइए।
ओके। आई थिंक यहां पे
जो लाइट है उसकी इशू हुई है थोड़ी सी।
अ ओके कोई बात नहीं। थोड़ी आपको लाइटिंग
का इशू आएगा अभी लास्ट में। अ लिटिल बिट
ऑफ तो उसको इग्नोर कीजिएगा। यहां पे
स्प्लंक जो है आपकी चालू हो चुकी है।
स्प्लंक हैज़ बीन स्टार्टेड। ठीक है? चलिए
मेरी फेस पे थोड़ी लाइट कम आएगी क्योंकि
जो लाइट लगी है वो शायद बंद हो गई है।
अपने आप बंद हो गई। पता नहीं क्या ही हो
गया उसको। अपने आप क्या हो गया। आई डोंट
नो।
ठीक है?
आई डोंट नो व्हाट इज़ दिस हैपनिंग। तो यहां
पे हमने फॉर ऑर्डर को रिस्टार्ट कर दिया।
अब हमें इसको टेस्ट करना है। टेस्ट कहां
पे करेंगे भैया? हम टेस्ट करेंगे अपने
स्प्ल डैशबोर्ड पे। यही तो हमारा काम था
स्प्लंक डैशबोर्ड पे। अब हम यहां स्प्ल
डैशबोर्ड पे जाएंगे सर्च एंड रिपोर्टिंग
पे। और सर्च एंड रिपोर्टिंग पर जाने के
बाद यहां पर सर्च करेंगे इंडेक्स
इंडेक्स
= Windows ये सर्च करेंगे एंड यहां पे
हमने सर्च पे क्लिक किया एंड लेट्स सी इफ
देयर इज़ समथिंग कमिंग देखो हमने इंडेक्स
इक्वल टू Windows अब हमें यहां पे अलग-अलग
तरह के सोर्स टाइप पे जाएंगे तो देखो
सोर्स टाइप मिल रहे हैं हमें सिक्योरिटी
सिस्टम एप्लीकेशन Windows यह आपको सोर्स
टाइप मिल रहे हैं। सोर्सेज में आप देखो ये
सारे सोर्सेस होस्ट में कौन सा होस्ट कौन
सा आया जहां से लॉग्स आ रहे हैं यह
डेस्कटॉप आई के टू एन आर 94 ये हमारा
बिल्कुल सक्सेसफुली सब कुछ हो चुका है। अब
हम यह आप इस पीसी का मैं आपको नाम भी दिखा
देता हूं।
आप इस पीसी का नाम देखो प्रॉपर्टीज
एंड
डेस्कटॉप आई के2 एनr 94 ये हमारी पीसी जो
है यह आपको दिख रही होगी यहां पे। सो इट्स
क्लियरली कि हमारे इस Windows के लॉग्स जो
हैं वो आपको इसके अंदर में आ रहे हैं।
यानी कि यह फॉरवर्डर जो है बिल्कुल सही
काम कर रहा है। लॉक्स को भेज रहा है। सब
कुछ कर रहा है। एवरीथिंग इज़ परफेक्टली
फाइन। तो मतलब हमें जो लॉग्स है वो मिल
रही हैं। एकदम मजे में मिल रही हैं। एंड
अब जो है यू आर गुड टू गो फॉर दिस
पर्टिकुलर सेटअप। तो यह सेटअप जो है एक
तरह से कंप्लीट हो चुका है। दिस इज
कंप्लीटली डन। ठीक है? कंप्लीटली डन। अब
इसी सेटअप के
को चेक करेंगे हम काली लinक्स के थ्रू भी।
क्योंकि हम काली लinक्स के थ्रू हम अटैक
करके एक बार चेक करेंगे कि लाइक अटैक इज़
वर्किंग ऑ नॉट। क्या चीजें काम कर रही है
कि नहीं कर रही हैं। तो हम काली से
Windows पे अटैक करेंगे। तो Windows की जो
आईपी है पहले वह देख लेते हैं। क्या आईपी
है?
इसकी आईपी कॉन्फिग
तो यह वही वाला मतलब करना है हमें जो
होस्ट ओनली वाली है तो 1928 232 तो 129 है
तो हम काली को अब स्टार्ट कर देते हैं।
लेट्स स्टार्ट द काली मशीन।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
काफी चीजें एक साथ चल रही है गाइस। मैं
आपको रैम यूटिलाइजेशन दिखाता हूं अभी
क्योंकि मेरा जो सिस्टम है वो हैंग कर रहा
है थोड़ा सा। यह देखो रैम यूटिलाइजेशन 54%
मेमोरी यूटिलाइजेशन हो रही है फिलहाल अभी
के टाइम में 19% CPU यूज़ हो रहा है।
बहुत ज्यादा यूटिलाइजेशन हो रही है RAM
की।
ठीक है?
चलिए तो काली को स्टार्ट करते हैं। काली
से हम अटैक करेंगे Windows के ऊपर में। वी
विल बी अटैकिंग ऑन Windows।
आई डोंट नो व्हाई दिस इज
नॉट
मैं एक बार ये लाइट का चेकअप कर लेता हूं।
व्हाई लाइट लाइट को क्या हो गया?
देयर इज़ सम इमेज सम इशूज़। सही नहीं होगी
वो। चलो कोई बात नहीं टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
करते। अब यहां पे हमने काली को लॉगिन
किया।
हमने काली लॉग इन किया। अभी देखो सबसे
लेटेस्ट लॉग जो है हमारे एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड
में वो कौन सी आई है? ये क्या आ गया भाई?
कौन सी आई है? सबसे लेटेस्ट लॉग ये आ रही
है 16 तारीख की आज की 104 PM की। अभी 10
ओके यहां पे आप देख रहे होंगे डेस्कटॉप i
के 2 एनआर का यह लॉग आया हुआ है सबसे
लेटेस्ट वाला। ठीक है? ये 1041 की है।
1041 73 PM ये आपकी आई है। ठीक है?
अब यहां पे काली में आया मैं ओपन टर्मिनल
किया। अब मैं अटैक करूंगा। एनम मैप कमांड
चलाऊंगा। एक सिंपल सा एन मैप कमांड
चलाऊंगा। एंड लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग।
तो मैंने यहां पे एन मैप कमांड डाला
एन मैप हफन एस वी एंड यहां पे मैं आईपी
दूंगा 192.168
232.129
आई थिंक यही आईपी थी हमारे Windows भाई की
हां तो मैं यहां पे एनमैप कमांड चलाता हूं
और मैं एंटर करता हूं। नाउ लेट्स सी
स्प्लक में हमें कोई एंट्री हमें कोई डेटा
मिल रही है क्या? तो स्प्लंक के अंदर में
हम आ चुके हैं यहां पे। एंड नाउ लेट्स
हमने यहां पे स्प्लक पे तो किया। अब हम
यहां पे
Windows वाले पे फिर से मैं यहां पर सर्च
करता हूं। लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज़ समथिंग।
यस। सो वी हैव
एनी लॉग। लेट्स सी
आई के टू आर यहां पे कोई लॉग आई है क्या?
नहीं यहां पे कोई यहां पे आपको कोई वो दिख
रहा है? चलिए मैं यहां पे ना एक फेक लॉग
इन वो करके देखता हूं। लाइक लेट्स फेक लॉग
इन एक बार करके देखते हैं। लाइक एक फेक
लॉग इन करके देखते हैं। उससे कुछ आता है
क्या? यहां पे इनप स्कैन में
आई थिंक सिस्टम डेस्कटॉप विंडज
अगेन लेट सी फर्डर ने कुछ फॉरवर्ड किया है
कि नहीं भैया
यहां पे यह हो चुकी है। यह
स्कैन हुआ है। फॉरवर्डर आई थिंक काम कर
रही है। फॉरवर्डर ने फॉरवर्ड किया होगा।
एंड हमारे Windows पे यहां पे लेट्स अगेन
डू वन थिंग। मैं अगेन चलता हूं सर्च एंड
रिपोर्टिंग पर। फिर से आते हैं।
यहां पर करते हैं इंडेक्स = Windows पे
एंड लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग। फेक लॉग
इन अटेम्प्ट करते हैं। अ हां, ठीक है। ये
वाली एक आई है। सबसे लेटेस्ट वाली। तो
डेस्कटॉप से ही आ रही है। इसी से आ रही
है। तो मैं शो ऑल लाइंस करता हूं यहां पे।
एंड यहां पर देखते हैं। डेफोनिक साइबर
इनरेट क्रेडेंशियल
ओके।
ऊपर लेट्स गो अबव
ठीक है सिक्योरिटी आईडी डिफ्रॉनिक्स साइबर
यह आई है हमारे पास Windows इवें ठीक है
और कुछ आई है क्या यहां पे आई डोंट थिंक
सो डेस्कटॉप डेस्कटॉप डेस्कटॉप डेस्कटॉप
डेस्कटॉप वाली आई है डेस्कटॉप वाली आई है
46 डेस्कटॉप वाली आई है
चलिए अब एक फेक एक
हां एक फेक लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट करके मतलब देख
लेते हैं। फेक लॉग इन लाइक आई डोंट नो बट
एक बार ट्राई कर लेते हैं। एक बार जस्ट
ट्राई करते हैं। फेक लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट करके
देखते हैं।
यहां पे एक फेक लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट करेंगे।
ठीक है? सो बेसिकली एसएमबी कमांड एक होती
है आपकी एसएम बी एंड क्लाइंट ये एक कमांड
होती है बेसिकली जिससे कि आप फेक लॉग इन
अटेम्प्ट करते हैं तो हफन एल मैं कर देता
हूं एंड यहां पे मुझे एक IP चाहिए जिस पे
मैं लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट करूंगा तो वो है
192.168.232.129
इस पे मैं एक फेक यूजर बनाऊंगा मतलब एक
फर्जी यूजर एंड यहां पे मैं फेक यूजर करके
अ फेक यूज़र्स करके एक यूजर बना देता हूं
एंड इस पे मैं एंटर करता हूं। अब ये
पासवर्ड मांग रहा है तो मैं यहां पे लाइक
कुछ भी पासवर्ड डाल देता हूं यहां पे
एंड यहां पे मैं एंटर करता हूं। तो ये आ
रहा है एंटी स्टेटस लॉग इन फेलियर। यहां
पे फेलियर लॉग इन का आया यहां पे। एंड
यहां पे मैं इसको रीलोड कर देता हूं। मैं
यहां पे क्या करता हूं? इसको अगर सर्च
करता हूं। लेट्स सर्च इट। सो लेट्स सी इफ
देयर इज़ समथिंग। तो यहां पर जैसे ही मैंने
यहां पर सर्च किया है यहां पर एक और इवेंट
आई है। यहां पे मैं 61 यह लाइंस करता हूं
और मैं एंटर नीचे आता हूं तो आपको दिखेगा
यहां पे कि एक जो लेटेस्ट इवेंट आई है वो
इवेंट आपके सिस्टम से आई है Windows
सिस्टम से। बट यहां पे क्या आ रहा है? एन
अकाउंट फेल्ड टू लॉग ऑन। यह एक हमारे पास
फेक लॉगिन का ऑडिट आ चुका है। यह आप देख
सकते हैं कहां से आया है। अकाउंट नेम फेक
यूजर से आया हुआ है। वर्क ग्रुप। नीचे की
तरफ आएंगे। अननोन यूजरनेम और बैड पासवर्ड
करके आ रहा है। और यहां देखेंगे वर्क
स्टेशन नेम में काली लinक्स आ रहा है।
वर्क स्टेशन नेम में आपका काली आ रहा है।
यानी कि काली से जो है ये आपकी आई हुई है
जो लॉग है काली से अटैक हुआ है। काली जो
है उसी मशीन से अटैक हुई है। तो इसका ये आ
रहा है। और साथ में सोर्स का पोर्ट नंबर आ
रहा है। यह सब कुछ आ रहा है। और यह जो है
IP आ रही है। जो काली की जो IP है 1921
168.232.130
यही IP है काली की हमारी। आपको मैं IP भी
दिखा देता हूं।
192 168 और 232.130 तो यानी कि यह वेरीफाई
करता है कि आपका जो सिम डैशबोर्ड है वो
Windows 10 पे जो भी अटैक हो रहे हैं उसके
उस अटैक को बेसिकली क्या कर रहा है? आपका
सिम डैशबोर्ड फॉरवर्ड कर रहा है। गॉट इट?
मतलब सिम डैशबोर्ड जो है आपका सिम
डैशबोर्ड के ऊपर फॉरवर्डेड आपके लॉग्स आ
रहे हैं। तो यहां पर सिंपल सा फंडा यह है
कि हमने काली से अटैक किया Windows 10 के
ऊपर में Windows 10 पे जो यूनिवर्सल
स्प्लक का यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर बैठा हुआ है
उसने एक उस सिक्योरिटी लॉग को सिंपल क्या
किया? फॉरवर्ड किया। कहां पे फॉरवर्ड किया
भैया? हमारे इस शिम डैशबोर्ड पे। सिम
डैशबोर्ड पे हमारे यहां पे इंडेक्स सर्च
जब हमने किया सर्च एंड रिपोर्टिंग में तो
हमें यहां पे लॉग मिल गई जिसका लॉक
टाइमिंग लॉग की सारी यह फॉर्मेट जिस तरीके
से होती है सारी डिटेल्स यहां पे आ चुके
हैं। यहां पे मैसेज आ चुके हैं एंड अकाउंट
फेल्ड टू लॉग इन एंड एव्रीथिंग यहां पे जो
चीजें हैं अटैकर से रिलेटेड वो सारी चीजें
आ गई हैं। अब इसमें अटैकर्स से रिलेटेड
बहुत सारी चीजें आई हैं। लॉग नेम
सिक्योरिटी है। सिक्योरिटी लॉग है ये।
इवेंट कोड 4625 है। आप ऐसे भी सर्च कर
सकते हैं। 4625 का सर्च करेंगे ना ऐसे भी
जैसे Windows तो किया यहां पे। अब यहां पे
मैंने यहां पे इवेंट कोड 4625 सर्च करेंगे
ना तो आप स्पेशली इसी इवेंट के लिए आप
इसको सर्च कर पाएंगे। तो यहां पे दो कुछ
इवेंट्स यहां पे हुए हैं 4625 से रिलेटेड
ये वाली। तो इसको जब वो एक्सपेंड करेंगे
तो आपको सारा चीज़ मिलेगा। सोर्स नेम
Microsoft Windows सिक्योरिटी ऑडिटिंग
रिकॉर्ड नंबर क्या है? ऑडिट फेलियर यहां
पे लॉग ऑन फेलियर यहां पे सब कुछ डिटेल
यहां पे आएगा। सब्जेक्ट में यहां पे ये
सिक्योरिटी आइडेंटिफायर का नंबर है यहां
पे सब कुछ फेक यूजर अकाउंट नेम कौन सा यूज़
हुआ फेक यूजर यूज़ हुआ है क्या इसका रीज़न
क्या है फेलियर का यूजरनेम या पासवर्ड गलत
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड है वो आपके यहां पे है
कहां से चालू हुआ काली से विक्टिम जो
अटैकर का आईपी क्या है यह है पोर्ट क्या
है भैया तो यह पोर्ट है यह सब कुछ ए टू
जेड एवरीथिंग इज़ देयर हियर ऑन दिस
पर्टिकुलर लॉक्स तो यह आपने एक पूरा का
पूरा सिस्टम सिस्टम सेटअप कर लिया है। एज
सिंपल एज दैट। जैसा मैंने बताया था कि
आपने काली मशीन से काली मशीन से Windows
पे टैग करा। Windows पे आपका क्या सेटअप
है? स्प्लंक फॉरवर्डर। Windows पे क्या
सेटअप है भैया?
स्प्लंक
यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्डर
यह सेटअप है। इसने क्या किया? स्प्लंक
फॉरवर्डर जो है यह लॉग्स लेगा। यहां से
Windows से Windows से सारे जो लॉग्स लेने
का सारा जो जिम्मा है ना यह
यूनिवर्सल स्प्लक फॉर ऑर्डर Windows से
लॉग्स लेगा।
ये लॉक्स लिया। यूनिवर्सल फॉर ऑर्डर को
भेजा। और इस यूनिवर्सल फॉर ऑर्डर ने ये
लॉक्स जो है वो कहां किया? स्प्लंक के सिम
मतलब जो स्प्लक डैशबोर्ड है मतलब स्प्लंक
को फीड कर दिया। स्प्लंक में आप उन चीजों
को जो है वो अब आप स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं।
उनको एक्सपेंड करिए। उसको रीड कीजिए। उसको
देखिए। यही तो होता है। यही तो पूरा का
पूरा गेम है। मैं इसको
एक मशीन बंद करनी पड़ेगी। नहीं तो सिस्टम
हैंग कर रहा है बहुत ज्यादा।
यही पूरा का पूरा गेम है। एंड इस तरीके से
आपने पूरा का पूरा एक एसओसी लैब सेटअप कर
लिया है। फुल एसओसी लैब यू हैव सेट अप
यहां पे जहां पे आपने उबू का यूज़ किया,
काली का यूज़ किया, हमारा होस्ट मशीन है
उसको यूज़ किया है। ये सब चीजें हमने यूज़
करके एंड एक पूरा का पूरा एसओसी लैब हमने
सेटअप कर लिया है। अब मुझे यह बताइए ये
पूरे एसओसी लैब सेटअप में आपको किसी भी
तरह की दिक्कत हुई किसी भी कंपनी में ऐसा
ही कुछ सेटअप होता है। एक अटैकर मशीन होता
है। एक अटैकर होता है जो अटैक करता है। एक
आपका जो मशीन जिस पे अटैक होता है।
Windows 10 हमारा था। और एक जो है आपकी
बेसिकली सिम डैशबोर्ड होती है जो हमने
स्प्लंक का सेटअप किया है। उबू के ऊपर।
उबू सर्वर के ऊपर हमने स्प्लंक सेटअप
किया। एंड हमने पूरा का पूरा एक एसओसी लैब
क्रिएट कर लिया। अब आप अटैक कीजिए काली से
Windows के ऊपर में। Windows के विंडज़ के
अंदर स्प्ल यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर सारे लॉक्स
को कलेक्ट करेगा जो हमने कॉन्फ़िगरेशन की
थी इनपुट्स डॉट आउटपुट डॉट तो इनपुट्स डॉट
में जो जो हमने कॉन्फ़िगरेशन की थी सिस्टम
सिस्टम लॉग सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स अ पावर शेल
के लॉग्स वो सारे लॉग्स जो हैं वो आपके
लॉग्स जो हैं वो सारे लॉग्स आपके आ गए
हैं। एंड उसके बाद आउटपुट्स में वही इस अह
जो आउटपुट्स कौन से भैया? आउटपुट्स डॉट
कॉन्स में हमने क्या डाले थे? स्प्लक का
इंडेक्सर जो था उसको सारे भेज रहा था वो।
एंड बस दैट्स इट। और आपका जो स्प्ल
डैशबोर्ड है उसके पास सब कुछ आ गया। एंड
आप मजे में अब आप सारी चीजें कर सकते हैं।
आप ईज़ली मजे में बना सकते हैं। अ उसको रीड
कीजिए। उसको स्टडी कीजिए। देखिए क्या
लॉग्स में क्या-क्या चीजें आ रही हैं।
हां, एक चीज़ मैं आपको बताना चाहता हूं।
मैं यहां पर इसको फिलहाल तो इसको बंद ही
करता हूं क्योंकि यह पूरी की पूरी इसने
पूरी बैंड बजा रखी है सिस्टम के। पावर ऑफ
कर देता हूं।
आई थिंक यह बंद हो चुका है। आई थिंक अब यह
थोड़ा स्मूथ हो जाएगा शायद। हां। हां। अब
मैं एक चीज आपको बताता हूं। यहां पे जो भी
चीजें हां हां हां हां फॉरवर्डर फॉरवर्डर
यूज़ स्प्लंक फॉरवर्डर इज अ वेरी पॉपुलर
टूल यार। इट्स बीइंग यूज्ड। स्प्रंक फॉलोर
इज बीइंग यूज्ड। नहीं, मुझे रिपीट नहीं
करनी है। अशोक सहनी जी, आपको यह वीडियो
रिपीटेड मोड में देखनी पड़ेगी। आपको यह जो
वीडियो है, यह आपको रिपीट मोड में देखना
पड़ेगा। ठीक है? जब आप रिपीट मोड में
देखेंगे, आपको बिल्कुल क्लेरिटी हो जाएगी।
आप सब अभी-अभी सोचेंगे भी ना आराम से जब
इस चीज को रिपीट करेंगे जब देखेंगे आपको
एग्जैक्ट आईडिया लग जाएगा कि हमने
एग्जैक्टली वही किया है जो मैंने आपको
यहां पर बताया हुआ है। हमने Windows होस्ट
मशीन जो हमारा मेन Windows मशीन है उस पे
VMware इंस्टॉल किया। VMware के अंदर तीन
यहां पे चीजें डाली। एक काली Linux,
Windows 10 या 11 डाल लीजिए। Ubuntu सर्वर
डाला। काली Linux एज़ अटैकर यूज़ कर रहे
हैं। Windows 10 11 विक्टिम की तरह जिसपे
अटैक हो रहा है। और Ubt सर्वर के ऊपर हमने
स्प्लंक इंस्टॉल किया। तीनों का होस्ट
ओनली नेटवर्क हमने सेटअप किया। एक नेटवर्क
नेट होगा, एक होस्ट ओनली नेटवर्क होगा। दो
नेटवर्क सेटअप किए होस्ट ओनली इसलिए ताकि
यह तीनों आपस में कम्युनिकेट कर पाएं। बस
हो गया। हमने काली लinक्स से अटैक किया
Windows 10 पे। Windows 10 पे हमने यहां
पे स्प्लंक यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर इंस्टॉल
करके रखा था। और इस इस यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर
के अंदर में हमने कॉन्फ़िगरेशन की थी
इनपुट्स. आउटपुट्स डॉट। इनपुट्स डॉट में
हमने डाला था कि किन-किन लॉग्स को हमें
कलेक्ट करना है। सिस्टम लॉग सिस्टम लॉग
सिक्योरिटी लॉग पावर पावर शेल के लॉग्स ये
सब चीजें हमें और हमें आउटपुट्स डॉट में
हमें उसको कहां भेजना है? तो हमें भेजना
था इंडेक्सर को जो कि हमारा कौन सा था?
स्प्लक का इंडेक्सर जो हमने उस एक आईपी पे
सेटअप की थी। तो हमने उस आईपी पे यहां से
भेज दिया। अब ये लॉग्स सारे इस प्लंक के
अंदर गए। सिम डैशबोर्ड के अंदर। सिम
डैशबोर्ड के अंदर हमें लॉक्स मिलने लगे।
जैसे कोई अटैक होगा हमें लॉक्स मिल
जाएंगे। हम उन लॉक्स को पढ़ेंगे, देखेंगे
एज एन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट उसको एनालाइज
करेंगे। उनको एग्जामिन करेंगे और उसके
अकॉर्डिंग हम देखेंगे कि किसको अलर्ट कौन
से अलर्ट को ट्रैक करना है, कौन से अलर्ट
को क्या करना है, आगे क्या स्टेप्स लेने
हैं, किसको एस्केलेट करना है, रिज़ॉल्व
करना है। व्हाटएवर यू हैव टू डू एज एन
एज एन लाइक एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एल1 यू विल
बी डूइंग दैट। बस यही तो करना था। और क्या
था?
यही तो था।
अब समझ में आ गया?
डिड यू अंडरस्टैंड एवरीथिंग
inputs डॉट फाइल आउटपुट.com की फाइल मैंने
खुद बना के रखी हुई थी आप सबों के लिए
एंट्री वाली। अगर आपको चाहिए होगा तो
प्लीज आप वीडियो देख लीजिएगा। इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट क्योंकि वीडियो में सब कुछ
मैंने मेंशन करके रखा हुआ है। एंड आप वैसे
भी आप Google सर्च करेंगे तो वह भी आपको
मिल जाएगा। कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है इसके
लिए। सो प्लीज यू कैन फॉलो दैट। ठीक है?
यस।
व्हाई होस्ट ओनली नेटवर्क? होस्ट ओनली
इसलिए ताकि जो तीनों मशीन है तीन वीएम्स।
होस्ट ओनली का मतलब यह होता है कि अगर
आपने एक वीएमर के अंदर में मल्टीपल सॉफ्ट
वीएम्स रखे हैं तो वो तीनों एक दूसरे से
कम्युनिकेट कर पाएं और बाहर की दुनिया एक
दूसरे बाहर की दुनिया उनसे कम्युनिकेट ना
कर पाए। इंटरनेट का एक्सेस ना रहे तो वह
एक सिक्योर तरीका होता है। होस्ट ओनली में
प्लेटफॉर्म्स की एप्लीकेशनेशंस की
टेस्टिंग होती है ताकि इंटरनेट का कनेक्शन
ना रहे और सिक्योरली टेस्टिंग हो सके। एक
दूसरे से कम्युनिकेशन हो सके और सारी
चीजें हो सके। इसलिए होस्ट ओनली नेटवर्क
का यूज़ किया जाता है।
ठीक है? समझ में आया या नहीं आया? बताइए
मुझे। कितने लोगों को समझ में आ गया?
कितनों के ऊपर से उड़ गया? मुझे जरा सभी
लोग बताइए।
आई वांट योर आंसर्स।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
नहीं L2 का पेड ट्रेनिंग आएगा। फ्री सीरीज
नहीं आएगी। L2 एंड L3 की पेड ट्रेनिंग
आएगी। L1 की फ्री सीरीज थी आपकी।
अंडरस्टुड? थोड़ा कॉम्प्लिकेटेड हो सकता
है। बहुत लोगों को लगेगा। उन सब से
रिक्वेस्ट है कि प्लीज वॉच इट अगेन। जिनको
भी थोड़ा कॉम्प्लिकेटेड लग रहा होगा। इस
पूरे वीडियो को एक बार फिर से देखिएगा।
अच्छे से एक-एक स्टेप को देखिएगा। मेंशन
उसको नोट कीजिएगा और उसको प्रैक्टिकली
परफॉर्म कीजिएगा। आप खुद से उसको
एग्जीक्यूट करके अपने सिस्टम पे कीजिएगा
एंड आपका काम हो जाएगा। एक बार आपने सेटअप
कर लिया इस प्लंक डैशबोर्ड पे आपके लॉग्स
आने लगे। सेटअप कंप्लीट एंड दैट्स इट।
ठीक है? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
finance.com आपने बोला था कि सर स्क्रीन
पर देख रहे हैं तो आपकी जो इनपुट्स डॉट और
आउटपुट्स डॉट की फाइल थी जो एंट्री थी वही
मैं देख रहा था कि इन inputs डॉट और
आउटपुट्स की जो एंट्री है वो मैं चाह रहा
था कि इधर लाऊं इस वाले सिस्टम पे। तो मैं
दूसरे सिस्टम से इस पे ला रहा था। बट वही
है कि मैं सोचा कि पेनड्राइव लगा के उसको
पीडीएफ फाइल पे लेकर आता हूं। तो वह
पीडीएफ फाइल लेकर आई और आप लोगों को वो
चीज़ बताई। यहां पे एंट्री जो बहुत बड़ी
एंट्री थी उसमें।
ठीक है।
सर कितनी क्लास है? क्लास अब एक या दो दो
या तीन मैक्सिमम दो या तीन क्लासेस बस बची
है इस सीरीज के एंड होने में। उसके बाद यह
सीरीज एंड हो जाएगी फाइनली। एंड इस सीरीज
से मेरी काफी एक अटैचमेंट हो रखी है काफी
टाइम से ये सीरीज चलती आ रही है। दैट्स
व्हाई। एंड मैंने इसमें अपना बेस्ट देने
की कोशिश की है आप सभी के लिए इस सीरीज
में। आई होप कि आपने उन बेस्ट को कलेक्ट
किया। उन वेस्ट को नरिश किया। इन्वेस्ट को
चैरिज किया एंड आपने करियर में काफी कुछ
सीखा उसको लेके आई होप कि आपको मजा आया भी
होगा ठीक है
ओके विनय महेंद्र विनय महेंद्र यू आर
रियली ग्रेट सर आई रियली अप्रिशिएट अभी
नाइट के 10:00 pm प्लस हो चुका है फिर भी
आप हमें पढ़ा रहे हो सच में सर इतना कोई
नहीं थैंक यू सो मच विनय ब्रदर फॉर योर
गुड वर्ड्स फॉर योर नाइस वर्ड्स थैंक यू
वेरी मच
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके
डू यू गेट ट्रेनिंग मतलब ट्रेनिंग फ्रेशर
होगे तो थोड़ा बहुत ट्रेन तो किया ही
जाएगा। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। नेक्स्ट सीरीज
कौन सी होगी? आप ही लोग बता दो नेक्स्ट
सीरीज कौन सी चाहिए आपको? आप बता दो
नेक्स्ट सीरीज कौन सी चाहिए? बग बंटी की
तो ऑलरेडी हो रखी है। तो फिर बग बंटी
क्यों बोल रहे हो? बग बंटी सीरीज हैज़
ऑलरेडी बीन कंप्लीटेड।
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एसओसी L1 सीरीज़ वाज़ वै गुड
वेटिंग फॉर एसओसी L2 L3 यू कवर्ड इट वेरी
वेल सर आई गॉट इंप्रज़ दिस
थैंक यू वेरी मच
फाइनेंस कॉम कोई बात नहीं अभी तो एक दो और
वीडियोस हैं आते हैं फिर उसमें देखते हैं।
ठीक है? चलिए। सो गाइस आज की जो क्लास है
उसको एंड करते हैं। दो या तीन मैक्सिमम और
क्लासेस में आपकी सीरीज एंड होगी। जो
चीजें थोड़ी बहुत और चीजें बची है मुझे
आपको बतानी है वो मैं बताऊंगा। हालांकि ये
सीरीज ऑलमोस्ट कंप्लीट है। कुछ चीजें जो
बची हैं मैं आपको बताना चाहूंगा वो
बताऊंगा। मैं आपको उन क्लासेस के थ्रू
लेकर आऊंगा। उसके बाद एक लास्ट सेशन के
थ्रू सीरीज रैप अप कर देंगे। एंड देन हम
एक नई चीज जो है उसकी तरफ बढ़ेंगे। उसको
स्टार्ट करने की ट्राई करेंगे। सोचेंगे
एंड वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग दैट। ठीक है?
कुछ आपके लिए नया भी लेकर आऊंगा। उसके लिए
बेफिक्र रहिए आप लोग। एकदम कुछ नया लेकर
मैं आने की प्लानिंग कर रहा हूं। आपके लिए
कुछ रिफ्रेशिंग, कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग, कुछ
करियर ओरिएंटेड कुछ एआई का इनफ्यूज़
आर्टिफिशियल इंटेलिजेंस से रिलेटेड चीजें
भी है क्योंकि आजकल एआई एआई हर जगह एआई
है। साइबर सिक्योरिटी में भी एआई है।
डेवलपमेंट में भी एआई है। हर जगह एआई है।
सो आई विल बी ट्राइंग टू ब्रिंग समथिंग
इंटरेस्टिंग रिलेटेड टू एआई साइबर
सिक्योरिटी रेड टीमिंग सब मिक्स करके कुछ
चीजें आने वाली है। तो आपको मजा आएगा
उसमें भी।
देखते हैं। सो लेट्स एंड द सेशन हियर फॉर
नाउ। थैंक यू वेरी मच। जाते-जाते लाइक ठोक
देना। और जब रिकॉर्डिंग देखना तो वीडियो
को हाइप करना, शेयर करना, लोगों तक पहुंचा
दो जहां तक पहुंचा सकते हो। एंड आई विल बी
वेरी ग्लैड फॉर दैट। सो टॉप फैंस की एक
बार लिस्ट हम देख लेते हैं भैया। वी
ऑलरेडी सी दैट। सो वी विल नॉट मिस आउट।
जी हां।
टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट में हमारे टॉप फैंस की
यह लिस्ट है जिसमें कि कुछ जाने पहचाने
नाम मुझे दिख रहे हैं जो ऑलरेडी हमेशा
होते हैं। एंड दैट्स ग्रेट यू गाइस आर
प्रेजेंट फ्रॉम ऑलमोस्ट स्टार्टिंग। मैंने
देखा है कि कई लोग तो बहुत शुरू से
प्रेजेंट रहे हैं इस सीरीज में। नाम भी
मुझे याद हो चुका है कई लोगों के। सो
दैट्स ग्रेट ऑफ यू गाइस दैट यू कंटिन्यूड
टिल हियर।
स्पिरिट है आपके अंदर वह चीज तो दैट्स
ग्रेट। हो गया।
ओके देन फिलहाल के लिए सभी को शुभ रात्रि।
गुड नाइट। टाटा टेक केयर एंड
स्लिप वेल। मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में।
बाय बाय।